GOOD MORNING.
WILL BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMANDER TO AN EDUCATION
FINANCE.
WITH A. S. SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND TODAY OF
COURSE WE'RE GOING TO BE
DISCUSSING THE EARLY EDUCATION.
AND.
.
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND.
OTHER AND MISCELLANEOUS.
THE.
ISSUES RELATED TO ESPECIALLY
RELATE ISSUE FOR WE KIND OF HAVE
THIS IS A CATCH ALL A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO HAVE IDEAS
PROPOSALS TO PUT IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SPENDING PLAN.
AND SO THAT'S REALLY GOING TO
HEAR FROM YOU THE PUBLIC
ADDITION NUMBER FOUR.
AT BEFORE THAT WE WILL BEGIN
WITH ISSUE NUMBER ONE MORE ABOUT
PROP NINETY EIGHT K. TWELVE
ISSUE ABOUT INCENTIVIZING FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN SO. I COME ON
UP THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
LA JOH IN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND AS YOU'RE A MAKING YOUR WAY
UP JUST TO REITERATE THAT THIS
SOB OVERALL BUDGET HEARING IS TO
FOCUS THEM ON A. FEW VARIETIES
BUT THAT THE FIRST AND FOREMOST
I THINK. IS THE EARLY EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW IT'S
CRITICAL IN. AT THE SUCCESS OF
OUR STATE'S FUTURE AS WELL AS.
YOUNGSTERS FUTURE.
AND THAT WE KNOW WE'VE COME A
LONG WAY THE LAST FEW YEARS.
STORING SOME OF THE CUTS IN THE
GREAT RECESSION BUT WE HAVE A
LONG WAYS TO GO AND IT WILL
BEGIN. THAT TODAY'S HEARING WITH
THAT IT KEEP IT WOULD THAT TO
KEEP IN MIND LOOKING AT
OPPORTUNITIES TO RESTORE THESE
CRITICAL PROGRAMS FOR
CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL FOCUS ON A
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN AND THAT
THE IDEA AND BECAUSE WE TALKED
ABOUT LAST YEAR FOLLOWUP ON
INCENTIVIZING FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN.
I AM GOOD MORNING RYAN ANDERSON
OF THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
SAYS THE CHAIRMANSHIP IN
TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
INCENTIVIZING FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN THIS IS A FOLLOW UP
FROM SOME SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE THAT THE. LEGISLATURE
ENACTED WITH LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
ASKING FIRST CD AND THEN OUR
OFFICE TO LOOK AT THIS QUESTION
OF.
HOW A COMMON IS IT FOR PROGRAMS
TO OFFER FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN?
AND WHAT COULD THE STATE DUE TO
FURTHER INCENTIVIZE PROGRAMS TO
SHIFT FROM PART DAY TO FOLD A
PROGRAMS.
SO CD .
CONTRACTED WITH THE TEAM FROM
UCLA THEY SURVEYED.
NUMBER DISTRICTS ABOUT SIXTY.
AND FOUND THAT OF MOST OF THEM
ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT WERE ALREADY
OFFERING ONLY FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS. OF THE
REMAINING FORTY PERCENT ABOUT
HALF OF THEM WERE OFFERING A
MAKES A FULL DAY IN PART DAY
PROGRAMS AND. THE OTHER HALF
WERE OFFERING ONLY PART A
PROGRAMS.
NOW WHAT'S INTERESTING HERE IS
THAT.
.
REGARDLESS OF HOW LONG A
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM IS OFFERED
THE STATE OFFERS THE SAME PER
CHILD FUNDING RATE ON TO THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
SO UNDER STATE LAW.
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS MUST WHAT
OPERATE AT LEAST THREE HOURS PER
DAY.
SOME PROGRAMS OPERATE MORE THAN
TWICE AS LONG AS THAT BUT IN ALL
CASES REGARDLESS OF HOW LONG THE
PROGRAM IS OFFERED.
DATE RECEIVE THE SAME PER CHILD
FUNDING RIGHT SO I THINK THERE
ARE SOME QUESTIONS A IN THE
LEGISLATURE IS WHETHER THAT
POLICY MADE SENSE AND IN
PARTICULAR. WHETHER
DIFFERENTIATED FUNDING RATES
SHOULD BE OFFERED FOR FOLDING
PARTY PROGRAMS.
NOW.
WHAT CD TO HE'S STUDY FOUND WAS
THAT EVEN UNDER CURRENT FUNDING
POLICIES MOST PROGRAMS ARE
OFFERING FULL DAYS? A
KINDERGARTEN THAT IN MOST CASES.
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT FULL DAY.
HAVE EXPRESSED AN INTEREST IN
OFFERING FULL DAY PROGRAMS BUT
THEY SAID A LACK OF FACILITIES
AS.
THAT PRIMARY BARRIER TO
OFFERING A FULL DAY PROGRAM.
NOW WHAT WE LOOKED AT WAS MORE
THE FISCAL SIDE WE ARE INTERESTS
IN THIS QUESTION OF WHAT ARE THE
PHYSICAL DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
FULL THEY IMPARTED PROGRAMS.
AND SOMEWHAT SURPRISINGLY WE
FOUND THAT IN MOST CASES.
PARTY PROGRAMS DON'T COST THAT
MUCH LESS THAN FULL DAY
PROGRAMS.
NOW IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT A
COST OF A KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM
IS IT IT CONSISTS OF A NUMBER OF
THINGS. START WITH THE CLASSROOM
ITSELF.
A MATERIALS ADMINISTRATION ALL
THESE THINGS TEND TO BE
RELATIVELY MINOR ON A PER CHILD
BASIS BECAUSE THESE ARE. COSTS
THAT ARE SPREAD OUT OVER A
NUMBER OF CHILDREN OFTENTIMES
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS.
IT ON A PER CHILD BASE IS THE
PRIMARY COST IS THE COST OF THE
TEACHER WHO'S LEADING THAT
CLASSROOM.
NOW IN THEORY APART A CLASSROOM
COULD SAVE SIGNIFICANTLY ON THE
COST OF A TEACHER IN ONE OF TWO
WAYS. ONE EIGHT EIGHT COULD HAVE
A SINGLE TEACHER LEADING TO
CLASSES EVERY DAY IT COULD LEAD.
OF MORNING CLASS IN AN
AFTERNOON CLASS OR TWO IT COULD
EMPLOYEE. THAT TEACHER IN A PART
TIME BASIS.
NOW WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT
NEITHER OF THESE OPTIONS ARE
REALLY EXERCISED OFTEN IN
CALIFORNIA FIRST.
IT'S ACTUALLY AGAINST STATE LAW
FOR A KINDERGARTEN TEACHER TO
TEACH TO KINDERGARTEN CLASSES IN
A SINGLE DAY.
WELL NOW IT'S NOT AGAINST STATE
LAW TO EMPLOY TEACHERS ON A PART
TIME BASIS BUT WE DO FIND THAT
IT'S A VERY UNCOMMON PRACTICE IN
MOST CASES.
EVEN KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS WHO
ARE LEADING ONLY A SINGLE PARTY
PROGRAM ARE EMPLOYED ON A FULL
DAY BASIS WHICH MEANS WHEN
THEY'RE NOT LEAVING A CLASSROOM.
THE CONDUCTING OTHER ACTIVITIES
MAYBE ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIVITIES
IN MANY CASES THEY'RE SERVING AS
AN AID IN ANOTHER PART DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM SO HOW THAT
WORKS IS IT WILL BE TO TEACHERS.
MISS SINGLE CLASSROOM ONE WILL
SERVE AS.
THE TEACHER IN THE MORNING AND.
IN EIGHT IN THE AFTERNOON OTHER
WILL SERVE AS THE EIGHT IN THE
MORNING TEACHER AND AFTERNOON.
NOW IF YOU'RE FOLLOWING THAT
PRACTICE.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THE PARTY
PROGRAM DOESN'T SAVE THAT MUCH
MONEY IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY
BECAUSE HE GETS TO SHARE THE
CLASSROOM.
A AMONG TWO CLASSES OF
ABSTINENCE TICKETS TO SHARE
EQUIPMENT AND OTHER MATERIALS
BETWEEN TWO CLASSES DISTANCE BUT
THESE COSTS ARE. RELATIVELY
SMALL BETWEEN THE TWO CLASSES.
BASED ON THESE FINDINGS FIRST
THAT.
UNDER CURRENT POLICIES MOST
PROGRAMS ARE ALREADY FULL DAY IN
SECOND THAT THERE ISN'T A
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN. THE COST OF OPERATING
FULL TIME PARTY PROGRAMS WE DO
THINK THAT THE STATE'S CURRENT
FISCAL POLICIES.
ARE SUFFICIENT TO INCENTIVIZE
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN BUT THE
STATE DOES HAVE SOME OPTIONS IF
HE WANTED TO FURTHER INCENTIVIZE
HE'S PROGRAMS.
FIRST BECAUSE HE BE FOUND AND
AND THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
WE'VE HEARD.
FROM THE FIELD THAT IN MOST
CASES THE BARRIER TO OFFERING. A
FULL DAY PROGRAM IS A LACK OF
FACILITY SPACE
THE STATE COULD OFFERS SOME
FACILITY GRANT SPECIFICALLY FOR
PROGRAMS INTEREST IN SHIFTING
FROM PART DATE FULL DAY.
KINDERGARTEN.
A SECOND THE STATE COULD
INCENTIVIZE FULL DAY PROGRAMS BY
OFFERING A LOWER FUNDING RATE
FOR PART A KINDERGARTEN NOW
BECAUSE THE COSTS AREN'T
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT.
BETWEEN THESE TWO PROGRAMS WHAT
WE DON'T THINK THERE'S A. A
SINGLE ANALYTICAL ANSWER FOR.
WHAT APART DAY RATE SHOULD BE AS
OPPOSED TO FULL THEY RATE BUT WE
DO THINK? THAT ANY CUT TO THE
PARK DAY RATE WOULD OFFER A
FURTHER FISCAL INCENTIVES FOR
SOME PROGRAMS TO START MOVING TO
FOLD A PROGRAMS.
I'LL LET THESE THERE. THE A TO
OPTIONS THAT HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT.
DESIGN ELEMENTS HERE QUESTIONS
I WOULD HAVE TO BE CONSIDERED IF
YOU GO DOWN THAT PATH AND.
A. OF COURSE WILLING TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS BUT.
THAT'S ALL MY PAPERS PREPARED
REMARKS.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OF EDUCATION.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH BROWN ON
BEHALF A STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM TOXIN AYE
I'LL JUST BUILD ON WITH THE LA
O. M. REPORT WHICH PROVIDED. A
GOOD SUMMARY OF WHAT THE AS
STUDY FOUND SO WHAT I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO DO IS JUST HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF ADDITIONAL POINTS FROM
THAT OF EVALUATION SO. WE REALLY
AS WE LOOK AT THE RESULTS WE
FIND THAT THAT.
THE FINDING SUPPORT THE NEED TO
LOOK AT HAVING SMALLER CLASS
SIZES AND ART ARE BETTER AT
TEACHER TO TO CHILD RATIOS
EITHER THROUGH. I'M HAVING IT AN
ADDITIONAL TEACHER IN THE
TO BEST SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF. THAT FORTY
QUE AND THEN ALSO APART DAY
PROGRAMS ABOUT DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS DOES HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE.
DISTRICTS THAT ARE ALREADY
HAVING A FACILITY SHORTAGE WHICH
IS LEADING TO THEM NOT BEING
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT A OR
RESTRICTING THEIR ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT FULL DAY PROGRAM. I'M
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
THAT WAS ALSO INTERESTING WAS.
MAKE SURE THAT WE CONSIDERING
THE DIFFERENTIATION AND FULL DAY
VERSUS PART THEY'VE WORKED
PRETTY QUE SO WE HOPE SO THE
REPORT SHOWED THAT SOME OF THE
TEACHERS FELT THAT.
WHILE THEY WOULD LIKE FULL DAY
FOR KINDERGARTEN IT WAS NOT
NECESSARILY APPROPRIATE FOR I'M.
T. CASE STUDENTS AND SO MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT THAT
WHEN WE WHEN WE DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN INCENTIVES FOR FULL DAY.
AYE CANDOR AND T. K. I'M ONE OF
THE OTHER THINGS WAS REALLY THAT
THAT I KEY FOR AYE NEEDING SOME
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT
INCLUDING AND SO. HOW AND
ACTIONS AND SO PROVIDING
MORE SUPPORT FOR TEACHERS COME
AROUND THOSE AND WAYS TO BETTER
INTEGRATE BOTH THE AT
KINDERGARTEN STANDARDS AND THEN
THE LEARNING FOUNDATIONS?
AND WILL ALSO LOOK AT DIFFERENT
WAYS TO CONCERT TO PROVIDE
PLANNING SUPPORT FOR A DISTRICTS
IS THAT SO THAT THEY COULD
TRANSIT TRANSITION TO A FULL DAY
PROGRAM SO NOT ONLY THINKING
ABOUT. PROPS BEST PRACTICES FOR
FOR ADDRESSING HAVING THAT THE
FACILITIES CONSTRAINTS ON IN THE
CLASSROOM SUPPORT. I'M A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE LA
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT I THINK
THAT THE.
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE ALLEY
รณ AROUND LOOKING AT PROVIDING
SOME.
SUPPORT OR INCENTIVE FUNDING
THROUGH EITHER GRANTS OR LOANS
ON THE FACILITIES WOULD BE A
GOOD THING FOR THE STATE TO. TO
A SUPPORT TO THAT THAT WOULD
REMOVE AT LEAST THAT ONE BARRIER
LIMIT THAT BARRIER TO
IMPLEMENTATION. AND WE WOULD
ALSO SUGGEST RATHER LOOKING AT
OTHER OPTIONS AND SUPPORTS FOR
ENCOURAGING MORE FULL DAY RATHER
THAN LOOKING AT REDUCING THAT.
THAT RATE FOR.
FOR AYE KINDERGARTEN AYE FOR
APART DAY PROGRAM SO WE GET
EIGHTY CAN COULD INCLUDE AN
ONGOING INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR
EVEN ONE TIME PLANNING SUPPORTER
MULTIYEAR PLANNING SUPPORT
RATHER THAN ONGOING FUNDING. AND
THEN I WOULD SAY IN RESPONSE TO
THAT QUESTION POSED IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT.
ABOUT HOW WE COULD UTILIZE THIS
INFORMATION AND PERHAPS DO LOOK
AT THE STUDY FOR FUTURE
CONSIDERATION UNTIL ULTIMATELY I
THINK WE THOUGHT THAT THAT. THAT
THAT EVALUATION WAS A GOOD ONE
BECAUSE IT WAS MULTIFACETED SO
IT INCLUDED THE SURVEYS THE
INTERVIEWS AND THEN ALSO THE
CLASSROOM OBSERVATIONS. AND WE
COULD REPLICATE THAT BY AND
DOING THAT EVERY TWO TO FOUR
YEARS IN THE ADVANTAGE TO THAT
WOULD BE YOU WOULD GET ON A
LITTLE BIT MORE LONG TERM DATA
BUT WE CAN ALSO PERHAPS MEASURE.
THE IMPACT IN TWO TO FOUR YEARS
AROUND THAT THE RECENT CHANGES
FOR IT CASE NAMELY THAT CHANGE
THAT JUST TOOK AFFECT AROUND NOT
HAVING TO HAVE TEA QUE QUE
BEING.
THE SAME TIME FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING INTERNET MEDIA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD LIKE TO
JUST KNOW THAT WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
WE DON'T HAVE A PROPOSAL
SPECIFIC TO THIS ISSUE AT THIS
POINT BUT BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL START OFF WITH WITH THE LA
OUT FACT I GUESS THERE'S IS TWO
FOLD IS THAT ONE IF YOU WANTED.
TO TO DO SOMETHING WHAT YOU WHAT
WOULD YOU DO AND TALK ABOUT A
COUPLE OPTIONS BUT. FRICKE FROM
YEAR BENEFIT FOR.
FOR CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE
FAMILIES AND AND.
THE STUDENTS AS FAR AS A SCHOOL
READINESS AB WHAT WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE OVERALL VALUE OF DOING
SOMETHING LIKE.
THIS WOULD BE TO TO FURTHER.
INCENTIVIZE AND PUSH THE OTHER
FORTY PERCENT TO GO FULL DAY.
PHONE SO ASIDE SAY THEY'RE
THEY'RE TWO PARTS TO THAT
QUESTION ONE IS WHAT IS THE
VALUE OF INCENTIVIZING FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN AND TWO IS. A
WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO APPROACH
THAT AT SAINT ON THE FIRST
QUESTION THAT LITERATURE IS
ACTUALLY A LITTLE MIXED A. THE
LITERATURE.
.
MANY STUDIES HAVE LOOKED AT.
WHAT ARE THE BENEFITS GENERATED
BY A FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN AND
IN MANY CASES THEY FIND THAT
WHILE THERE ARE POSITIVE
BENEFITS?
AND IN TERMS OF STE
STUDENTS WHO ATTEND FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS TO HAVE
HIGHER TEST SCORES IN LATER
GRADES. THE BENEFITS ARE WITHA
IN MANY CASES RATHER MARGINAL.
AT SO THAT QUESTION DOES BECOME
IT
HOW HIGH OF A PRIORITY SHOULD
THIS BE.
NOW.
IT IS THE CASE IN MANY STATES A.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT PRACTICES
AROUND HELD KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMS ARE STRUCTURED IN
PARTICULAR. AND MANY STATES PART
DAY PROGRAMS ARE RUN SUCH THAT
ONE TEACHER WILL BRIGHTEN A
MORNING CLASS ONE WALDRON AN
AFTERNOON CLASS THAT MEANS THAT
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT. COST
DIFFERENCE IN PROVIDING THESE
PROGRAMS AND THAT'S ALSO
SOMETHING OF THE STUDIES
TYPICALLY TAKE IT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT SO THE STUDIES. MANY
CASES SAY.
WHAT IS THE ADDED COST OF
RUNNING A FULL DAY PROGRAM
VERSES THE ADDED BENEFIT AND
THEY WILL FIND IN SOME CASES
THAT?
THAT THE COST OUTWEIGHS THE
BENEFIT THIS PROBABLY NOT THE
CASE IN CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE OUR PART DAY PROGRAMS.
TEND TO COST ABOUT AS MUCH AS A
FULL DAY PROGRAM SO EVEN ON A
MARGINAL. IT IMPROVEMENT AND
BENEFITS WILL PROBABLY OUTWEIGH
THE COST OF A. FURTHER
ENCOURAGING FULL DAY PROGRAMS.
NOW WITH THAT IN MIND THE
QUESTION BECOMES WHAT IS THE
BEST WAY TO INCENTIVIZE OF FULL
DAY PROGRAM A.
WE THINK THAT THE APPROACH THAT
IS BEST TARGETED TO THE SPECIFIC
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
THE FIELD IS SOMETHING TO
ADDRESS AT THE AVAILABILITY OF
FACILITY SPACES. NOW THAT COULD
BE STRUCTURED IN MANY WAYS IT IT
COULD BE. A A GRANT PROGRAM I
COULD BE A LOAN PROGRAM
UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T BE A CARVE
OUT FROM THE EXISTING PROP FIFTY
ONE FUND FUNDING BECAUSE OF
RESTRICTIONS A A IN THE LANGUAGE
OF THAT. PROPOSITION BUT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE MANY
OPTIONS IF IT WAS INTERESTING
THAT.
AND THEN AS FAR AS THE BENEFITS
YOU KNOW THERE'S THE ACADEMIC
BENEFITS BUT OF COURSE THERE'S
FAMILY BENEFITS AND.
CHILD CARE CONSIDERATIONS IN.
HAVING THREE DAYS OR THREE HOURS
THAT THAT YOU KNOW.
SOMETHING FREE FOR YOUR CHILD TO
DO VERSUS FIVE. WORKER PARA OR
MORE. YEAH I THINK THAT'S A FAIR
POINT AND IT.
DOES NOT APPEAR TO ME THAT THE
LITERATURE OFTEN TRIES TO
QUANTIFY THOSE BENEFITS OF THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT'S
MISSING FROM. THE CURRENT
LITERATURE.
OKAY.
QUESTIONS.
YES MISTER MADONNA SO SO WHY DO
WE WANT WILL A CANDOR I'M STILL
STRUGGLING WITH THIS.
IT SEEMS TO ME.
THAT.
OUR OUR CHILDREN ENTER THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP WOULD BENEFIT
MORE FROM FULL DAY CANTOR THAN
THOSE WHO ART.
DO WE HAVE EIGHT DOT DATA
RELATIVE TO THAT BECAUSE WHERE I
COME FROM AS IT SHOULD BE AN
EDUCATIONAL OF HEARD. IT
SHOULDN'T BE ABOUT DAYCARE WHEN
I HEAR PEOPLE WANT DAYCARE.
DAYCARES EXPENSIVE I GET IT BUT
I DON'T KNOW THAT'S NECESSARILY
ALWAYS THE STATE'S OBLIGATION.
SHOULD BE ABOUT EDUCATION NOT
ABOUT JUST PROVIDING.
YEAH DAYCARE FOR THE FULL DAY
I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE I LIKE MY OWN CHILDREN
WENT TO PARTY.
DOING FINE BUT I KNOW THAT WE
ALSO HAVE HAVES YOU KNOW SUMMER
TO FALL INTO THE CHIMNEY CAP
THAT I IMAGINE WOULD VERY MUCH
BENEFIT FROM CALLED A CANTOR.
SUCH AS I MEAN IT TO HEAR THE
WORDS MOSTLY RESTORING THERE'S A
REAL PROBLEM OUT THERE WOULD
IDENTIFY THE PROBLEM BEFORE WE
TALK ABOUT THE SOLUTIONS.
YEAH I WILL SAY THAT THE WOULD
IT SURE DOES OF SUGGEST THAT
THERE ARE ECONOMIC BENEFITS TO
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN MAY JUST
TEND TO BE RATHER SMALL.
.
NOW I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH ANY
STUDIES THAT SPECIFICALLY LOOK
AT ARE THOSE BENEFITS LARGER FOR
CERTAIN POPULATIONS OF STUDENTS
FOR EXAMPLE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ENGLISH LEARNERS SO. THAT I AM
AFRAID I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT
SPECIFIC SHOULD AGAIN THANK YOU
I I JUST THINK WE SHOULD FOCUS
ON CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
RATHER THAN PROVIDING DAYCARE
THAT'S WHY BECOME A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
AND IF WE NEED TO PUSH MORE
DOLLARS. INTO THOSE CLASSROOMS
THAT HAD TO HAVE THOSE STUDENTS
THAT ARE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE.
TO FALL UNDER THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP THAT'S WHERE WE SHOULD GO
WITH THEIR DOLLARS THAT'S WHERE
WE SHOULD GO WITH THEIR EFFORT
NOT JUST PROVIDING DAYCARE I GET
IT IS APPARENT. IT'S EXPENSIVE
I'D LOVE FOR THE STATE TO PAY
FOR IT BUT THE SAME TIME I THINK
A PURSUIT PURPOSE HEARS ABOUT
CLOSING THAT ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAVEZ.
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD THIS
DISCUSSION ON. THE ROLE OF.
EARLY KAGYU DEVELOPMENT
CHILDREN FOR A NUMBER YEARS
CHAIR AND I THINK.
BOTH REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATS
HAVE HIGHLIGHTED THIS AREAS OF
AN ISSUE.
BUT I'M GONNA GO BACK TO.
.
THE TERM USED EARLIER ON THE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING THEIR
CHILDREN.
THE.
IS THERE ANY STUDIES IT.
SHOW HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE A
WHAT WHAT IS THE BEST SETTING
FOR THIS IS IT. IS IT EIGHT
HOURS IS FOUR HOURS WHAT IS
ANYTHING THAT SHOWS.
FOR THE CHILD.
ABILITY TO.
IBM HAD DIRECTED SYSTEM.
WHAT IS THE WEB'S BEST?
EXPERIENCE.
A I'M NOTPERSONALLY FAMILIAR
WITH ANY OF THAT I I WILL SAY I
WERE. A.
THE AT THE LA O. OUR PRIMARY
INTEREST IN LOOKING AT THIS
QUESTION WAS ON THE FISCAL SIDE
SO WE WERE WE WERE NOT AROUND
YOU.
YET STEP AROUND A YET I DIDN'T
SORT OF BUILDING ON ON MR
O'DONNELL'S COMMENT AS WELL JUST
IF I REALLY THINK WHAT WE FOUND
AS WE LOOK AT AND I CAN'T SPEAK
TO ANY OTHER.
BUT STUDIES BUT WE CAN
CERTAINLY LOOK INTO BUT AS AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE EVALUATION
AND THE RESPONSES FROM THAT THAT
THAT TEACHERS. WHAT THEY FOUND
WAS REALLY JUST THIS IDEA UPS
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE HAVE CLASS
SIZES AS LARGE AS THEY ARE THAT
HAVING THE FULL DAY PROGRAM SO
THAT YOU KNOW IF OF? MORE THAN
FOUR HOURS ALLOW THEM MORE TIME
TO NOT ONLY GO OVER THE THAT
THAT CONTENT STANDARDS WITH THEM
WITH THEIR WITH THEIR STUDENTS
BUT THEN ALSO SPEND MUCH TIME ON
SOME OF THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING AS WELL. AND THE IDEA
THAT THEY COULD TAKE WHAT ONE
TEACHER THAT TURNED IN THE IN
THE EVALUATION BRAIN BREAKS SO
IT SO HAVING THAT THE FULLER DAY
PROGRAM. GAVE THEM MORE TIME
AGAIN IT IT IT INCLUDED A
MULTIPLE OF FACTORS NAMELY ONE
STARTING WITH LARGE CLASS SIZES
BUT THE WHOLE AND THEY NEEDED
MORE TIME BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
LARGER CLASS EXACTLY SO MAYBE HE
ANSWERS A SMALLER CLASS SIZE.
MISS REGARDING ANY KIND OF THIS
ARE DOMINANT IN DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN MY CHILD I WENT THROUGH
A TWENTY TO ONE A MUCH OTHER
WINTER THIRTY FIVE TO ONE THEIR
PERFORMANCE EVEN TODAY. THEREIN
LIES THE AND THAT THE SUMMERS
EFFECT.
CHAVEZ IS.
I SPOKE TO MY COMMENTS SO I
JUMPED AND I APOLOGIZE.
YOU DID REFERENCE MY COMP SO I
TOOK THE LIBERTY I APOLOGIZE.
GET IT WILL MAKE SURE WE KNOW
WHAT THE RULES ARE THE.
I WANTED TO GO ON THE ISSUE OF A
PARENTAL CHOICE NOW.
WHAT IF THE PARENTS WANT TO
THEIR ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE?
EARLY DEVELOPMENT OF THE
CHILDREN'S.
WHERE THEY LEANING TO?
I'D SALUTE CD IS A STUDY WAS
REALLY FOCUSED ON FISCAL
PERSPECTIVE.
AT SO.
THAT PARENTAL INPUT WOULD ONLY
BE IN DIRECTLY FROM WHAT IT
SCHOOLS THINK THAT PARENTS ONE I
I DO THINK THAT THE GENERAL
IMPRESSION IS THAT.
PARENTAL INTEREST IN MOST
COMMUNITIES THE TRIPS TOWARDS
THE FULL DAY PROGRAMS FOR MANY
OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UP.
IN PREVIOUS COMMENTS HERE ABOUT
JUST IT CAN BE INCONVENIENT FOR
PARENTS WERE WORKING TO. HAVE TO
PICK UP. A CHILD IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE DAY YOU MAKE AN ECONOMIC
ARGUMENT WILL BETTER THE PARENTS
WANT AS FAR AS A SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT OF THE
CHILDREN.
I I DON'T HAVE ANY INFORMATION
ON ON ON THAT AT THE MAKE AND AS
MISTER ANDERSON SAID THIS STUDY
WAS REALLY AROUND WHAT TEACHERS
AND AND SCHOOL LEADERS WANTED I
CAN CHECK TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYTHING. THAT THAT QUANTIFIES
HOW PARENTS FEEL ABOUT THE
LONGER DAY VERSES THAT THE
SHORTER DAY BUT I THINK THE
OTHER ISSUE IS REALLY FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE MORE TIME AT SCHOOL
IT IS EASIER FOR THEM. MS BROWN
WHICH IS AS FAR AS THE COST OF
THE. OR PAY FOR QUALITY TEACHERS
IN THESE PROGRAMS.
ARE THEY COMPATIBLE TO LET'S SAY
A FIRST OR SECOND GRADE. TEACHER
WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT TO PAY FOR.
SO I I BELIEVE THE ANSWER IS E.
IS YES ALTHOUGH THAT THAT IS
PART OF A AT DISTRICTS A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
SO WHAT'S WHAT'S YOUR VIEW
EITHER WHEN YOU KNOW ACROSS THE
STATE.
SOMEBODY'S GOING IN THESE
PROGRAMS ARE THEY PAID
COMPARABLE TO.
YES IN MOST CASES.
ALL MULTIPLE SUBJECTS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHERS ARE
PAID ON A UNIFORM SALARY
SCHEDULE BASED ON THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND EDUCATION. SO THE
ONLY DIFFERENCE THEN IS.
OF THEREFORE OUR CLASS OR NAY
TO OUR CLIENTS NO ACTUALLY IN
MOST CASES I'D EVEN IF YOU'RE A
TEACHER WHO'S LEADING ONLY A
FOUR HOUR CLASS. AS LONG AS
YOUR.
EMPLOYED ON A FULL TIME BASIS
YOU'RE RECEIVING THE SAME SALARY
AS SAY A THIRD GRADE TEACHER.
SO THE FACT THAT WAS ONE MY
CONCERNS ALSO IS THE MAKE SURE
THAT THE.
I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE.
QUALIFIED TEACHERS IN THERE IN
THE ENVIRONMENT AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE.
PREPARED BEING GIVEN ALL THE
TRAINING AND AND ALL THE SKILLS
TO BE THE BEST LIKE AND THEIR.
AND THE LAST STATEMENT I'LL JUST
MAKE A STATEMENT NOT A.
MIA DANCERS THE FACT THAT.
RESERVE WAYNE AND I THINK SO
HEAVILY IN THIS IS IT DEMANDS IN
OUR SOCIETY TODAY WITH SINGLE
PARENT FAMILIES YOU KNOW DUAL
FAMILY WORK GAME. WHEN THEY WERE
CHILDREN GOING TO BE IN. AND IN
AN IDEAL SITUATION THE CARE BE
AGREES THAT.
YOU KNOW OF OF A CHILD WE AT
HOME DEVELOP AND LEARN AT THEIR
OWN LEVEL AND WHATEVER ISSUES
ARE BUT WE KNOW THAT.
THAT'S NOT REALITY ME IN MANY OF
OUR NOW.
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE STRESS
ECONOMICALLY.
AND THAT IN ITSELF COST AGAINST
GOING TO CHILDREN WE KNOW THAT
THE OBJECTIVE IS THAT WHEN THE
CHILDREN. DOES GO TO SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW FIRST.
THAT THEY'RE PREPARED TO DO THAT
INTO MANY OF OUR CHILDREN
SPECIAL COLOR GOING TO SCHOOL
THEY'RE NOT PREPARED BECAUSE OF
THEIR. ECONOMIC SITUATIONS I.
I THINK THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THING WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
THIS MY SIXTY YEAR HERE HERE AND
THE SONG DISCUSSION SHOULD WE DO
IT.
WE WANT TO DO IT.
I THINK WHAT YOU NEED WHERE TO
POINT NOW IS.
.
ARE WE BEING SUCCESSFUL IN IT.
AND HOW MUCH MORE MONEY TO WE
GOTTA PUT INTO IT.
IN.
AND THIS IS A QUESTION YOU KNOW
WE HAVE THE SCORECARD COMING
OUT.
IS THIS PART OF THE EVALUATION
AND MISS BROWN IS.
AS WERE EVALUATING
YOU KNOW THE.
SUCCESS AN EDUCATION IS IS BEING
MEASURE GAP. SECOND CARE WE ARE
REFERENCING THAT THE CALIFORNIA
THAT SCHOOL DASHBOARD YET SO
AND.
YOU THE ANSWER IS YES AND NO
BECAUSE WE'D WE ALSO DON'T HAVE
WE DON'T ADMINISTER THE AND
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENTS UNTIL
THIRD GRADE SO IT DOESN'T HAVE
THAT ACADEMIC COMPONENT. BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT SCHOOLS ARE
USING I'M THEIR OWN.
AT ADDITIONAL INDICATES OR
DISTRICTS ARE USING AYE
INDICATORS A LOCALLY DETERMINATE
ACHE INDICATORS THEY COULD
CERTAINLY LOOK AT THAT THERE'S
ALSO OTHER INDICATORS. AROUND
AND CONDITIONS AND CLIMATE BUT
AROUND THE ACADEMICS PER SE IT'S
NOT PART OF THAT BECAUSE WE
DON'T DO THIS STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENTS ABOUT GREAT.
SO THE ANSWER IS A FROM A
PARENT.
DO I BE ABLE TO GO TO ANYWHERE
TO SEE HOW WELL THE SCHOOL
DON'T.
E. YOU CAN BUT IF YOU'RE TRYING
TO LOOK JUST SOLELY AT
KINDERGARTEN IT'S IT'S NOT
MEASURED IN AND THAT WAY THE
SAME AS IT IS. IN THE UPPER
GRADES.
SHOWS NO.
RIGHT
IT THOR EDGAR CALLED THE LEADS
THAT ABOUT FIVE IF I WOULD HAVE
MEANT THAT I THINK. THAT THEM
MOST OF SHOULD TO BE TAUGHT THEM
THEY HAVE SOME KIND OF
MEASUREMENT THAT THEY'RE DOING
IT THEY KINDERGARTEN FIRST GRADE
SECOND GRADE SURVEY. IF FOR
EXAMPLE THEIR THIRD GRADE TEST
SCORES ARE NOT ARE NOT GREAT
THEY MIGHT LOOK AND SAY OKAY
WHERE DO WE THINK THE START AND
IN SOME CASES THAT MIGHT. MEAN
BEING ABLE TO SAY OKAY WE THINK
THAT THEY SHOW UP IN CANADA ARE
NOT PREPARED AND AND I THINK
RIGHT NOW WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE.
WE'RE NOT USING ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE
KINDERGARTEN BUT DEFINITELY A.
MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS PART OF
WHAT WILL BE HEARD OF THEIR
THEIR ACTIONS ARE TAKING TO TRY
TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR THEIR
STUDENTS IN THE LONG RUN. IF THE
FOCUS MORE ON AYE MICKEY
IMPROVEMENT THAT YOU CAN EARN
RTK FIRST GRADE.
BUT IT'S NOT.
BECAUSE WE DON'T START
MEASURING THE BETH BACK TO THE
SORT OF THIRD GRADE WE DON'T
HAVE SORT OF THIS.
THIRD PERFORMANCE MEASURE THAT
WE LOOK AT THE GET THE CONVERT
RATE WE'VE NEVER HAD ANYTHING AT
THAT AT THAT EARLY IN THE.
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
REFRESH MY MEMORY.
.
WE STARTED DOING TO T. K. WHEN.
TWENTY TEN GUY I THINK THE FIRST
COHORT WITH ELEVEN TWELVE BUT
THAT WAS THAT WAS ONLY ONE MONTH
SO SO RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW IT'S
THREE MONTHS UPELIGIBILITY IS
WITHIN A THREE MONTH WINDOW AT
FIRST IT WAS JUST. ONE MONTH OF
ELIGIBILITY WE SORT OF A FAITH
THAT IN SO THAT I THINK FIVE A.
IT'S LIKE THE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
YEAR WHEN WE HAD THE FOR FULL
COOPER AS WE HAD NO CAME
FOURTEEN AND SO.
SO THE CHILDREN WHO AND FOURTEEN
RIGHT NOW IF THEY'RE IN THERE
AND THIRD GRADES WILL BE ABLE TO
SEE.
HOW IT'S GOING IS THAT CORRECT?
I THINK THAT THE THIRD YEAR NOW
STARTING TO GET A STUDENTS WHO
WERE INTRODUCED NUCLEAR AND WHEN
OUR IN THIRD GRADE AND WE'RE
STARTING TO FEE. THAT WE WOULD
HAVE.
ASPECTS COURSE FOR THEM THAT'S
THAT'S CORRECT HAVE YOU NOTICED
THE IMPACT YET.
I DON'T THINK I MEAN WE HAVE I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S ANYTHING
SPECIFIC THING THAT WE CAN FEED
THAT'S TIED TO THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN.
.
YOU KNOW I WE ALSO IN THAT
DURING THAT PERIOD ALSO CHANGE
STEPHENS WILL HAVE THREE YEARS
WORTH OF TEST WE HAVE SEEN.
FROM THE FIRST FROM FIRST YOU'RE
THINKING YOU'RE A BIG INCREASE
IN AFFECT SCORES A LOT MORE FLAT
IN FROM A AND FROM THE SECOND TO
THE THIRD YEAR.
SOME OF THAT THAT I I DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH OF THAT WE COULD
TIED TO WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON AT
THE TO KILL BUT VERY SOMETHING
THAT.
RIGHT ASSUMING THAT THAT
DISTRICTS COULD BE LOOKING AT
BECAUSE DISTRICTS WILL NOW HAVE
BOTH STUDENTS WHO ARE WHO WERE
TO QUE STUDENT INSTANCE
WE'RE NOT TAKING STUDENTS IN THE
FAME CLASSROOMS IN. SECOND THIRD
FOURTH GRADE TO YOU THAT THERE
MAY BE A A CONSENT THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE ABOUT BENEFITS.
I WILL HAVE A HEARING LATER ON
WAS SUMMONED AND.
EDUCATORS THAT HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED THIS FOR FOUR YEARS IT
COULD GIVE THAT OBSERVATION.
ANTITANK PARA.
SURE WHEN WE HEAR THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT SIDE THAT I THINK
THAT CERTAINLY SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER WE DID AGENDA IS THIS
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS YOU HAD AT
A PANEL ON. T. K. HOW IT'S
WORKING AND I WILL SAY THAT. THE
A OUR STUDY CAME OUT TUESDAYS IN
LAST.
EIGHTEEN MONTHS SEWING JACK
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS OF TEA QUE.
IN THE IN THE COURT OF THE KIDS
THAT WERE IN THE TICKET
CLASSROOMS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
TO TO TALK ABOUT THAT. THIS THIS
IS S. FOCUS PRIMARILY TODAY ON
THE EARLY AT PROPOSALS AND WE
DID PUT IN. THIS PIECE I'M KIND
OF AT. THE HYBRID WHAT INSPIRES.
A FULL DAY QUE THANK YOU.
SOME REMEMBER LIMON.
I THINK YOU AND I REGRET THAT I
AM JOINING THE CONVERSATION A
LATE THAT FROM MY AYE.
BECAUSE I ALSO KIND OF WANTING
TO COMMENT ON.
IN. WHAT THE EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES MIGHT BE RIGHT SO
THERE'S THE PIECE THAT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED WHICH IS THE
INVESTMENT THE FINANCIAL
INVESTMENT WE MAKE IN LOOKING
INTO AT A FULL DAY PROGRAM?
ANY THINK THAT AT LEAST FOR ME
MY THOUGHTS ON WHETHER THE
INVESTMENT.
IT IS THE RIGHT APPROACH ALSO
DEPENDS ON THE OUTCOMES WE GET
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S BEEN.
A LOT OF RESEARCH ON EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS EARLY
CHILDHOOD PROGRAMS AND THE
IMPACT THEY HAVE PARTICULARLY ON
FIRST NATION COLLEGE BOUND.
STUDENTS COMING FROM LOW INCOME
BACKGROUNDS AND.
.
I YOU I THINK YOU MENTIONED THE
ASSESSMENT.
CASE THAT CASE I AM I MAKING
THAT UP IS THAT I FEEL LIKE
THERE'S A AT LEAST IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS A PART OF A SCHOOL
BOARD WE DID HAVE A KINDERGARTEN
ASSESSMENT TEST.
AND THAT'S HOW.
.
IT YOU KNOW IT'S WHEN YOU SIT
DOWN SHAPES EITHER THE I MEAN I
SAT THROUGH THEM AND WATCH THEM.
AND.
.
THERE WAS A CLEAR DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN.
STUDENTS WHO HAD A PRIOR BY YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT WAS T. K. OR
PRESCHOOL OPPORTUNITIES VERSUS
THOSE THAT DIDN'T.
I MEAN YOU HAVE THE FIRST FIVE
MODEL THAT CONSTANTLY TALKS
ABOUT THE THREE YOU KNOW MILLION
WORDS THAT STUDENTS ARE NOT
EXPOSED TO IF THEY DON'T HAVE AN
EARLY CHILDHOOD CHILDHOOD KIND
OF EDUCATION PROGRAM. AND SO I
JUST DON'T KNOW IF WE COULD
COMMENTS A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THE EXPECTED OUTCOME FOR AN
INVESTMENT
UNLIKE THIS THAT THERE ENOUGH
THERE'S A FINANCIAL INVESTMENT
BUT.
THE OUTCOME OF TRANSITIONING TO
FULL DAY AND WHETHER OR NOT
THERE IS A BELIEF THAT I.
THAT THIS WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE A
GREATER IMPACT ON.
FIRST GENERATION LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AS OPPOSED TO STUDENTS
UP TO OTHER STUDENTS.
A.
YEAH.
SO.
I I WOULD SAY THAT THE BILL OF
LITERATURE THAT'S WILL DONE
SPECIFICALLY THE QUESTION OF THE
ACADEMIC BENEFITS FOR A FULL DAY
VERSES PARTY PROGRAMS HAS
GENERALLY CONCLUDED THAT THERE
ARE BENEFITS FOR FULL DAY
PROGRAMS BUT THEY TEND TO BE
QUITE SMALL. CERTAIN THAT
SPECIFICALLY STUDENTS TO ATTEND
A FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM
TEND TO DO BETTER ON TEST SCORES
IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS BUT THE
IMPROVEMENT IS A IS IN MANY
CASES MARGINAL.
AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT YOU
THAT YOU ARE CORRECT THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF KINDERGARTEN
READINESS ASSESSMENTS THE CASE
THAT BEING ONE OF ON THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ONE. CALLED THE
DESIRED RESULTS DEVELOPMENTAL
PROFILES SO THERE ARE A VARIETY
OF ASSESSMENTS THAT YOU CAN
GIVE.
TIP PRESCHOOLERS AND AND THEN
STUDENTS ENTERING T. CARE QUE
THAT ASSESS THEIR KINDERGARTEN
READINESS.
AND I WILL NOTE THE SOMEONE
MARILYN ON THAT THAT NEXT
THREE ITEMS ARE REALLY GET INTO
THE LARGER QUESTION ON.
I PREPARATION SUCCESS FOR OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS SO WITH THAT
SCRIPTURE CAN ADJUST MATHIS
O'DONNELL QUESTION A COMMENT BUT
AGAIN. I THINK.
WHERE I COME FROM IS I I WANT
TALK ABOUT THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
OF MARENGO FOR WITH THIS EFFORT
NEEDS TO BE ABOUT CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP? AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT I'VE HEARD ANY
STUDIES.
CITED TODAY RELATIVE TO THAT
QUESTION BUT I ALSO THINK YOU
KNOW WE OUGHT TO THINK ABOUT
SOME OTHER THINGS IN THIS ROOM
IS FULL THEY CAN HER ONE
TEACHER.
AT A LOT OF PREPARATION
FOR ONE TEACHER BECAUSE
KINDERGARTNERS ARE USING THEIR
HANDS ARE CUTTING UP THINGS.
THAT THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
TEACHER PREPARATION THAT GOES IN
TO THE KINDERGARTEN DENTICLE HE
AS I RECALL HAVING MEDICAID FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS. THE
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS WHO TEACH
OUR CLASS YES
THEN THEY GO INTO ANOTHER
CLASSROOM.
SPEND SOME TIME IN THERE WITH
MAYBE THE AFTERNOON CLASS.
AND THEN THEY'D HAVE MAYBE AN
HOUR MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME TO GO OUT PREPARE FOR THE
NEXT DAY. I JUST DON'T ONE
UNDERSCORE HOW MUCH PREPARATION
IS REQUIRED HANDS ON PREPARATION
IS REQUIRED FOR TEACHING A
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOM AND PUT
THAT ALL ON ONE PERSON.
SEE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE THIRTY
FIVE KIDS THIRTY EIGHT KIDS FOR
SEVEN HOURS OF THE DAY. AND THEN
YOU'VE GOT TO PREPARE FOR THE
NEXT DAY AFTER THAT DATE JUST
THERE'S A LOT THERE'S A LOT OF
LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
BUT THAT THAT CLASSROOM.
MOVE FOR THE STUDENTS BY BY
THAT BY THAT KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER SO JUST PLEASE THINK OF
THAT THINK OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING
TO THE TEACHER WHEN YOU DO THAT.
OKAY WITH THAT.
WE'LL CALL THAT PUBLIC COMMENT
BUT ON THE WAY UP.
I WILL NOTE THAT THANKFULLY WITH
ELSE IF THAT A COUPLE YEARS AGO
WE HAVE LOWERED. THE CLASS SIZES
TO THE YOUNGER GRADES BUT NOT TO
THE DEGREE THAT THEY WERE LOWER
THEY NOT QUE WHERE ONE TO TWENTY
ALLEN NOW OR WHAT MAYBE TODAY
ONE TO TWENTY SIX IN SOME
DISTRICTS IN SOME DISTRICTS
DON'T EVEN HAVE CLASS SIZE
REDUCTION SO.
OKAY YEAH PUBLIC COMMENT CAN YOU
LINE UP IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK AND DOES ARE DOING THAT WE
WILL TAKE ALL.
MCCARTY.
HERE. CHรกVEZ THERAPY MOAN HERE
MEDINA MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL YOUR
VOEPEL LOOK. OKAY SING NO PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE WILL GET
TO THE NEXT ISSUE ON LICENSING
THIS WAS A BIG PROPOSAL LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET.
AS FAR AS THAT THE PRESCHOOL
LICENSING PROPOSAL RELATE TO.
T. K. AND AND.
.
PRESCHOOL CLASSROOMS.
AND WE HAVE THE LA OUT
AFFIRMATIVE AT CURRENT FINANCE
AS WELL AS PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD MORNING I'M.
EVERY.
GOOD MORNING EVER COULD BOTH THE
LEADS THAT AROUND WITH A FIFTH
UMPIRE I WAS.
I'M GONNA PROVIDE SOME
BACKGROUND ON.
.
THE FAKE OUR OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM A WORK GROUP THAT I WE WERE
ASKED TO PROVIDE. WHAT TO DO
WITH PART OF THE US SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT LEGISLATION?
ARE AND THIS IS ALL RELATED TO.
THE LICENSING REQUIREMENTS FOR
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT
ARE OPERATED BY ELEAZAR IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. AND THAT
ARE LOCATED ON ELLIOTT FLAGS LA
FACILITIES.
I'M SO JUST VERY QUICK
BACKGROUND IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
LIFE WE THING A LICENSING RULES
AND STANDARDS ARE NOW WE HAVE TO
SET THE STANDARDS OUT ONE ARE
KNOWN AS TITLE TWENTY TO. OUR
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS
THESE ARE THE STANDARDS THAT
APPLY TO. ALL LICENSED PROVIDERS
ACROSS THE STATE AND THAT
INCLUDES BOTH WEBSITE PROGRAMS
AND AB PRIVATE PAY PROGRAMS ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. I'M THESE ARE
AGAIN FOCUSED ON HEALTH AND
SAFETY ARM AND THEY'RE
ADMINISTERED OUT THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSINGI'D
DOES THE MISSILE LIKE SOMETHING
AND THEN THEY DO A. OF VISITS
THROUGHOUT A RANDOM VISITS AND
THEY ALSO DO VISITS.
RELATED TO.
COMPLAINTS.
AND THEN WE HAVE ANOTHER SET OF
STANDARDS KNOWN AS TITLE FIVE
STANDARDS WHICH ARE MORE ABOUT.
MORE DEVELOPMENTAL STANDARD
THERE ABOUT PROGRAM CURRICULUM
AND THEY APPLY SPECIFICALLY TO
UP PROGRAMS THAT CONTRACT
DIRECTLY WITH THE STATE AND THE
THE BIGGEST PROGRAM IS THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
I'D THROW IT IN THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BUDGET THERE WAS
TRAILER LEGISLATION THAT. THAT
EXEMPTED.
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
OPERATED BY ELEAZAR AND RUN ON
LTA FACILITIES.
I'M FROM.
THESE TITLE TWENTY TWO HEALTH
AND FIFTY STANDARDS
AND IT WAS THE ONLY TO FALL THE
TITLE FIVE DEVELOPMENT OF
STANDARDS.
AT THIS EXEMPTION WAS TO TAKE
EFFECT JULY FIRST OF TWENTY
NINETEEN.
SO FELLOW BUT MORE THAN A YEAR
FROM NOW I'M IN THE LEGISLATION
REQUIRED OUR OFFICE TO CAMINO
STAKEHOLDER GROUP TO OUR TO
REVIEW THAT THE EXISTING OUR
REGULATIONS AND AND.
STATUTE AND DETERMINE WHETHER
THERE SHOULD BE ANY ADDITIONAL
OUR REQUIREMENTS ADDED TO
ELEAZAR.
REGARDING HEALTH AND SAFETY
GIVEN THE THAT ALL OF THE TITLE
TWENTY TWO STANDARDS WERE GOING
TO GO AWAY.
I'M AND THAT THE GROUP WAS
REQUIRED TO LOOK AT THREE
SPECIFIC AREAS.
OUTDOOR SHEET STRUCTURES
ACCESS TO AGE APPROPRIATE
BATHROOM AND DRINKING WATER
FACILITIES.
AND PROPHECIES FOR PARENT
NOTIFICATION AND RESOLUTION
VIOLATIONS.
AND SO WE WE DIDN'T I
COMMUNICORP WITH A STAKEHOLDERS
AND THERE WAS THE OTHER THE
GROUP WITH STAKEHOLDERS OUT OF.
THREE WHICH WERE NOT ONLY A
PROVIDERS THREE WERE ELLIOTT
PROVIDERS AND THAT WE HAD
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF BAD DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES. AYE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
AT AND LEGISLATIVE STAFF WHO
ARE PART OF THIS GROUP I'M THE
GROUP REVIEWED.
THE STANDARDS IN YOUR AGENDA ON
A. PITCH SEVEN HAS BEEN PICKING
UP SOME OF THE THAT THE A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE GROUP I
WOULD PUT THEM INTO CATEGORIES
ONE CATEGORY IS THIS.
A SET OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ADD ADDITIONAL REGULATIONS TO
TITLE FIVE STANDARDS.
I'M ABOUT CA NINETY FIFTH FIGURE
ON THE TOP PAGE SEVEN THEIR
NUMBERS OF THAT THE STANDARDS OF
THE GROUP RECOMMENDED SO SO WITH
SO THE FIRST FEW ARE ALL RELATED
TO THE THINGS THAT WE THAT THE
GROUP OF AFTER. TED.
REVIEW NOT REQUIRING THAT
OUTDOOR SHE'D.
EXIST AND ISN'T SAFE IN GOOD
REPAIR. FEDERAL KING WATER BE
ACCESSIBLE AND READILY AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
BUT FACILITIES HAVE ONE TOILET
AND WASHING FIXTURE FOR EVERY
FIFTEEN CHILDREN.
THAT RESTROOMS ARE ONLY BE
AVAILABLE OFFER PRESCHOOLS AND
KINDERGARTENERS PRESCHOOLERS
INCOME EARNERS ABOUT FOR OLDER
CHILDREN.
I'M AND THEN THERE WERE A COUPLE
OTHER THAT THE OTHERS OF THE
GROUP THOUGHT WERE IMPORTANT
ADDED ONE BEING THAT THE STAFF
MUST MAINTAIN VISUAL SUPERVISION
OF CHILDREN. AND THAT INDOOR AND
OUTDOOR SPACE BE PROPERLY
CONTAIN DEFENSE STAND AND
PROVIDE ENOUGH SPACE FOR THE
MEMBERS CHILDREN USING IT.
I'M SO THOSE ARE ALL OF.
A REQUIREMENT THAT THERE THE
GROUP WOULD RECOMMEND AT BEING
ADDED TO TITLE FIGHT REGULATIONS
THEY ARE ALL EITHER VERT
VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL OR VERY
SIMILAR TO SOME OF THE EXISTING
TITLE TWENTY TWO RULES I'M BY
ONE OF THE. VERY SMALL SHARE OF
THE EXISTING TACTILE TWENTY
STANDARDS ARE PRETTY LARGE. BOB
IS PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL O.
HANDBOOK OF THOSE REQUIREMENTS
VISIT THESE ARE A FEW THAT
EITHER WERE REQUIRED BY THE.
BY LET LEGISLATION TO BE
REVIEWED BY THE GROUP OR THAT
THE GROUP THAT WERE IMPORTANT
ENOUGH TO AT.
THE SECOND SET OF OF
RECOMMENDATIONS IS REGARDING
CHANGES IN STATUTE AND AT ALL OF
THOSE WRECK RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
RELATED TO THE UNIFORM COMPLETE
PROCEDURES.
I'M FOR THE THE WORKGROUP
RECOMMENDED THAT I AM PROUD THAT
THE UNIFORM COMPLETE PROCEDURES
BE UTILIZED TO PROP TO OUR
RESOLVE ANY COMPLAINTS.
FROM PARENTS OR ANY OTHERS OUT
REGARDING HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES IN STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
DOT AND IT'S SPECIFICALLY THAT
THE WORKGROUP RECOMMENDED THAT
THE TIME LINES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY USED FOR WILLIAMS
RELATED COMPLAINTS.
BE USED FOR STATE PRESCHOOL
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND SO THAT
MEANS THAT A THAT ANY COMPLAINT
WOULD NEED TO BE RESOLVED WITHIN
A THIRTY DAYS.
BY A SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THAT
THE COMPLAINT WILL BE NOTIFIED
WITHIN FORTY FIVE DAYS.
ON THE DAY OF THE WORK THAT THE
WORKGROUP ALSO RECOMMENDED
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT CURRENTLY
IF YOU SEE PEOPLE BUT A BED THAT
THEY RECOMMENDED IS THAT THE.
THE DISTRICTS BE REQUIRED TO
START INVESTIGATING THESE
COMPLAINTS WITHIN TEN DAYS
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS A VERY
SIMILAR TO AN EXISTING TITLE
TWENTY TWO REQUIREMENTS WHERE IF
SOMEONE DOES CALLED THE. HOTLINE
AND COMPLAINTS THAT YOU FEEL
THAT THERE'S SOME ISSUE GOING ON
ENOUGH ENOUGH FACILITY.
IF THE DOG GOES AND THAT THE
FACT THAT WITH INTENT IF.
SO THAT'S A QUICK SUMMARY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE GROUP I
THINK WE THOUGHT THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE FOR
REASONABLE WE PICK THE PAID TO
ADD SOME.
THAT EXPECTATIONS FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY THAT WEREN'T THERE
BEFORE OUT WITHOUT ANY TITLE
TWENTY TWO STANDARDS AT ALL BUT
THEY DO STILL PROVIDE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY
TO OPERATE THEIR PROGRAMS.
TERAPLEX COMBINED PROGRAMS WITH
FROM THE SMOKING GUN WAS JUST
WAS PART OF THE INTENT OF THAT
THE LEGISLATION. THANK YOU COME
SO BEFORE WE GET ON TO PARTNER
EDUCATION CAN YOU JUST WALK
THROUGH FOR THE CAN MEAN THE
PUBLIC HOW THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
WORKSHOPS LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
ACTION AND WHAT WE WOULD NEED TO
HAPPEN FOR THESE TO.
GOING TO FACTORED TO FALL BACK
ON.
THE STATUS QUO WHAT WE ADOPTED
LAST YEAR IN THE BUDGET RECOVER
DODD THE WAY THAT THE STATUE.
LEAVE OUT THE EXEMPTIONS WILLIG
WALK BIG VENTURE WILL TAKE
EFFECT JULY FIRST NINETEEN
ABSENT ANY OTHER ACTION. ITEM
THAT RIGHT NOW WITH THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE TITLE
FIVE REQUIREMENTS CAN BE DONE
THROUGH REGULATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF ED BUT LOOK THE
LEGISLATION SAYS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS AUTHORITY TO. TO
OUR DEVELOP EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS ARM AT THE RESULT OF
THIS VOTERS THAT SORT OF A A
BUILT IN MECHANISM FOR SOME OF
THOSE. TO TAKE EFFECT.
THAT DATE THE RULE CHANGES TO
THE UNIFORM COMPLETE PROCEDURES
THAT REQUIRE STATUTES OF THAT
WOULD NEED TO GO THROUGH EITHER.
IN A BUDGET TRAILER LEGISLATION
OR A SEPARATE BILL I'M BUT IT
DOES REQUIRE I'M SOME KIND OF
CHANGE IN STATUTES SO I THINK
THAT THE WROTE THE TIMING OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WAS INTENDED TO
BE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS SO THAT. IF THERE WERE
CONCERNS FROM THE LEGISLATURE
THERE WITH INTERESTED MAKING
STATUTORY CHANGES THAT THEY CAN
BE HEARD. OUT THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS ARM BUT ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT ANY CHANGES ARE ARE ANY
LEGISLATION IS ADOPTED AT THE
RESOLVE THE STAKEHOLDER GROUP.
THE EXEMPTION WILL BEGIN TO TAKE
EFFECT JULY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
HI SARAH NOVEL MORGAN AND. FOR
REPRESENTING US STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TOM PRODUCTS AND.
SO WITH THAT APARTMENT IS IN
AGREEMENT WITH NEEDING TO
ADDRESS AND INCLUDE ALL OF THESE
WE WOULD BEGIN IN SPRINGS ARE
JUST AND RIGHT NOW. AS THE
WRITING PACKETS FOR THE
EMERGENCY RAGS BASED ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE REQUIRED TO
PROMULGATE EMERGENCY RAGS ON OR
BEFORE. JULY FIRST OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN.
IN THE EMERGENCY RAGS PROCESS
THEY DO NOT ACCOMMODATE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD BUT WE FEEL THAT
THERE IS ENOUGH STAKEHOLDER
INTEREST ON A LOT OF PEOPLE
WANTING TO SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE.
THAT WE WOULD PLAN TO SOLICIT
STAKEHOLDER INPUT PRIOR TO
DEVELOPING THE REGULATIONS.
THOSE EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
WOULD BE DEVELOPED OVER THE
SUMMER FORCE THE MIDDLE AND
EARLY TWENTY NINETEEN. THEN
OBVIOUSLY ONCE UPON THE RELEASE
OF THOSE WE WOULD BEGIN THEN
PRIME AYE GETTING PERMANENT
REGULATIONS THROUGH THE NORMAL
AWAY OUT PROCESS WHICH INCLUDES
THAT PUBLIC COMMENT. BUT AS I
STATED A MINUTE AGO WE WOULD
FIRST HAVE STAKEHOLDER INPUT
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS OUT THERE
THAT WANT YOU. HAVE MORE TO SAY
ON THAT. AND IN THE WINTER OF
TWENTY NINETEEN THOSE
REGULATIONS WOULD BE PROMULGATED
AND IN THE SUMMER TWENTY
NINETEEN THE REGULATIONS WHAT
BEGAN. BUT AS I SAID WE'RE IN
AGREEMENT WITH WHAT THE STATE
COLOR WORKGROUP CAME UP WITH AND
KNOW THAT THERE ARE OTHER AREAS
OF CONCERN THAT THEY WANTED TO
ADDRESS AS WELL.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE
IN MINING BEYOND OFFENSE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AYE WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS TIME WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY NEW PROPOSALS
RELATED TO THIS ISSUE. ARE
UNHAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE.
ANY RESPONSE TO THIS STAKEHOLDER
SUGGESTION SO FAR.
I.
I I THINK OF THE SUGGESTIONS.
YOU TOOK INTO ACCOUNT A LOT OF
THE CONCERNS OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
HOT AND I KNOW THEY'LL BE GOING
PROCESS THAT WE'RE HAPPY ABOUT
SOMETHING. OKAY.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
NOT WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM
.
GOOD MORNING DO NEED A STRONG
GRIN SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF LOS
ANGELES.
AND THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER. ON WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH AN AMP AND
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THE EXEMPTING
OF ELEAZAR. FROM THE TITLE
TWENTY TWO.
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS.
WE HEARD IN THE LAST.
AGENDA ITEM ABOUT SOME OF THE
SERIOUS ABOUT FACILITY
CHALLENGES THAT FACE OUR LOCAL
SCHOOLS. AND ONE OF OUR CONCERNS
IS THAT.
CLASSROOMS AND OTHER SPACE MIGHT
BE USED INAPPROPRIATELY FOR THIS
AGE GROUP.
WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF SOME OF
THE PRE OPERATION ALL HEALTH AND
SAFETY REVIEWS.
.
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT.
THERE'S A LACK OF AWARENESS OF
THE. REALLY DIFFERENT
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS OF THIS
YOUNGER GROUP.
AND WITH THE ELIMINATION OF
UNANNOUNCED INSPECTIONS.
TRANSPARENCY AND CONSUMER
REVIEWS THAT CURRENTLY EXIST
WITHIN THE LICENSE SIX SYSTEM.
THAT IT WILL FURTHER CONFUSED
PARENTS
AND NOT PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF STATUS
OF THE PARTICULAR PROGRAMS.
WE SUPPORT THE STAKEHOLDERS
GROUP RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A
COMPLAINT PROCEDURE.
FOR ANONYMOUS COMPLAINTS AND
PARTICULARLY FOR THE TIMELINE
FOR THE RESOLUTION.
AND WE URGE OF A ROBUST ONGOING
CONVERSATION TODAY ABOUT TO
FURTHER EXPLORE AND DISCUSS SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES CONCERNS WE
HAVE WITH REGARD TO THIS. THEY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND AND I NEGLECTED TO
MENTION IF YOU CAN TRY TO KEEP
IT TO ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD MORNING NEED A FAITH
THE.
CALIFORNIA CHILD DEVELOPMENT
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION.
MY ORGANIZATION ALSO HAS SOME
VERY SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS HERE THREE YEAR
OLDS WHO MAY NOT BE POTTERY
TRAINED IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE WE BELIEVE THAT ARE
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLD SHOULD
BE IN THE SAFEST CONDITIONS THAT
WE POSSIBLY CAN PUT THEM AND. SO
THAT TITLE TWENTY TWO AS WAS
NOTED EARLIER IS A VERY VERY
VERY BIG ALONG REGULATION SOME
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP ARE FABULOUS
WE DEFINITELY SUPPORT THOSE
HOWEVER THIS IS ONLY AT THE TIP
OF THE ICEBERG THERE ARE MANY
OTHER HEALTH AND SAFETY
REGULATIONS IN HERE. AND WE
REALLY FEEL THAT I'M OUR
YOUNGEST CHILDREN NEED TO BE IN
THE SAFEST PLACE POSSIBLE
REGARDLESS OF THE SETTING ON
WHETHER PRESCHOOL AS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING PATTY PRUNE YOUR
BIRTH FROM THE CHILD CARE LAW
CENTER. I'M I I WANT TO FOCUS ON
THE A CONSUMER AND PARENT.
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES THAT ARE
RAISED I THINK OF THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMITTEE DID A GOOD
JOB OF ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY BUT THIS IS AN
AREA THAT WE HAVE PARTICULAR
CONCERNS ABOUT.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE A VERY GOOD
PROTECTIVE STRUCTURE WHERE THERE
CAN BE AN ANONYMOUS COMPLAINT
IT'S INVESTIGATED WITHIN TEN
DAYS BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY ALL
THAT INFORMATION ABOUT THE
RESOLUTION OF THE COMPLAINT AS
WELL AS. THE LICENSING
INSPECTION IS UP ON A PUBLIC
WEBSITE SO APPARENT LOOKING FOR
A CHILD CARE.
SPOT AT A PRESCHOOL CAN KNOW
WHAT KINDS OF VIOLATIONS HAVE
OCCURRED AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'VE BEEN RESOLVED WE ARE
LOSING THAT TRANSPARENCY THROUGH
THIS PROCESS AND. I'M.
CONCERNED THAT.
.
pPRESENT THEIR ON THEIR VIEWS ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT. CONSUMER
WEBSITE AND I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT. THAT'S THE DIRECTION THAT
ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS ARE MOVING
AND SEE ARMED ARE FEDERAL CCD
BEING SHE IS TALKING MORE ABOUT.
THE PUBLIC AWARENESS OF.
SAFETY.
RECORDS OF THESE.
PLACES WHERE REPLACING OUR
YOUNGEST CHILDREN AND I WOULD
ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THAT ASPECT.
YOU.
MONEY FROM US ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE LA US WE'D LIKE TO AND
EXPRESS SOME OF OUR CONCERNS AT
THE LA A WORK GROUPS.
RECOMMENDATIONS DID NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH TO BALANCE HEALTH AND
SAFETY AS WELL AS DEVELOPMENTAL
APPROPRIATENESS.
.
WE ARE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
THAT ANY OF THESE FLEXIBILITY
USE. SHOULD BE LIMITED TO FOUR
YEAR OLDS
THREE YEAR OLDS ARE IN A VERY
DIFFERENT LEVEL DEVELOPMENTALLY
AND THESE ARE CHILDREN WHO AT
TIMES ARE NOT POTTY TRAINED AND
WE THINK THAT THOSE FLEXIBILITY
IS JUST NEED TO BE KEPT A FOUR
YEAR OLDS.
IN ADDITION AND WE THINK THAT
ANY OF THE WORKGROUP
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT PROCEED
PARTICULARLY MOVING REQUIREMENTS
OVER THE TITLE FIVE BEFORE THAT
HAPPENS THEIR NEEDS TO BE A
CONCRETE PLAN. WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES WOULD PARDON OF
EDUCATION HAS GIVEN ACCESS.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES CONSUMER COMPLAINT
DATABASE SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO UPDATE THOSE
COMPLAINTS.
SO THAT PARENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
SEE WHAT'S OCCURRING WHETHER IT
WHAT'S OCCURRING WITHIN THE LEN
COMPLAINTS
IN ADDITION WE THINK ONE OTHER
IMPORTANT.
.
BROOKE ONE OTHER IMPORTANT
PROTECT SAFETIES PROTECTION IS.
COVERING EXPOSED ELECTRICAL
OUTLETS
THERE WERE A LOT OF STORIES
ABOUT CHILDREN WHO WERE STICKING
THINGS INTO OUTLETS AND SHOCKING
THEMSELVES DOWN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE THINK THIS IS AN
INEXPENSIVE FIX THAT CAN EASILY
BE ADDRESSED.
AND THEN FINALLY WE AGREED THAT
THE ONLY.
RECOMMENDATION WAS NOT AN
EXHAUSTIVE REVIEW OF TITLE
TWENTY TWO.
REQUIREMENTS AND AND WOULD
REQUEST THAT AN EXHAUSTIVE
REVIEW TAKES PLACE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ALEX TO CAPRI ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA
AND I MYSELF AT FIRST BY
VALLEY'S COMMENTS THINKING.
LOW THE CORNISH CALIFORNIA
CHILDCARE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
NETWORK AYE IT WOULD LIKE TO
MIRROR THE STATEMENTS AND MOST
OF MY COLLEAGUES AND WE DO
SUPPORT SOME OF THE STAKEHOLDER
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT I'D LIKE TO
SHARE WITH YOU A PERSONAL STORY.
LAST
WEEK I HAD TO MAKE A COMPLAINT
AGAINST A FACILITY THAT MY
GRANDDAUGHTER WAS SOON. AND
THERE WAS CONSTANT COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE MYSELF THE PARENT
AND COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
THESE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS ARE
GOING TO BE LOST WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE MAINTAINED.
IT'S IT'S.
JUST SO IMPORTANT FOR THE FAMILY
TO FEEL LIKE THEIR CHILD IS IN A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CANDOR HARRIS WITH
CHILD ACTION ARE ECHOING THE
COMMENTS OF PREVIOUSLY SAID WE
HAVE SINCE SEVERE CONCERNS. ARE
WE DO THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
MORE EXHAUSTIVE RESEARCH DONE ON
THIS.
AND YOU KNOW HOLDING CHILDREN.
IN THE MOST UTMOST CARE IS
CRITICAL TO THEIR SAFETY AND
DEVELOPMENT SIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER CRAPPIE
WITH PARENT VOICES CALIFORNIA
AND ARE FIFTEEN CHAPTERS ACROSS
THE STATE. WOULD LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO CONTINUE TO BRING THE
VOICE OF PARENTS TO THIS ISSUE.
ASIDE THE ISSUE OF SAFETY FOR
OUR CHILDREN IN CHILD CARE. IS
CRITICAL AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FIND OUT
ABOUT LICENSING VIOLATIONS TO BE
ABLE TO. A REPORT VIOLATIONS
WHEN THAT HAPPENS AND TO DO
THAT.
.
THROUGH AND THE EASE OF
LICENSING AND THEIR EIGHT
HUNDRED NUMBER IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S NOT LOST IN
THIS NEW PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING THANK YOU THIS IS
VALERIE TO NARROW IT
CALIFORNIANS FOR QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING AND I WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO. THE SENTIMENTS OF THOSE
BEFORE ME WE AGREED WITHTHE
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE COME UP TO
EXPRESS OUR CONCERN ABOUT.
SUPERVISION HEALTH AND SAFETY
THEIR OVER FORTY NINE THOUSAND
LICENSED CHILDCARE PROVIDERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
WORK VERY HARD ALONG THE SIDE
OF.
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING TO
ENSURE THAT THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE OPERATING CHILDCARE SERVICES
HAVE WORKING KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT
IT MEANS TO PROTECT A CHILD
HEALTH AND SAFETY. THE WEBSITES
BEEN UPDATED THERE'S BEEN SOME
GREAT INTERACTIVE VIDEOS AND
TRAININGS OF HAPPENED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF CHILDREN. AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE MORE AND MORE CHILDREN OVER
TO THE K. TWELVE. AND PUBLIC
SAID SECTOR WE ARE TAKING AWAY
THOSE CONSUMER AND SAFETY POINTS
THAT WE'VE PUT SO MUCH EFFORT
INTO. SO I URGE YOU TO TAKE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND KNOW
THAT.
ALTHOUGH CHRONOLOGICALLY YOU MAY
BE AT AGE FOUR YEAR OLD
DEVELOPMENT ONLY YOU COULD BE AT
AGE TWO YEAR OLD ON THE
CONTINUUM. THAT EARLY CHILD
EDUCATION IS BIRTH YOU TWELFTH
AT TWELVE YEARS OF AGE AND WERE
NOT ALWAYS WHERE WE ARE
DEVELOPMENTALLY ON THE CONTINUUM
SO PLEASE.
AND TAKE THOSE CONSIDERATIONS
INTO PLACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE JUDGE JEFF BACA REPRESENTING
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
JUST WANTED TO.
QUICK COMMENT THAT OBVIOUSLY THE
HEALTH AND CARE OF THE CHILDREN
THAT ARE.
BEING SERVED IN THE LA SETTING
IS OF PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE TO.
I RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND. MY LA COLLEAGUES
AND REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT.
THERE ARE TITLE FIVE YEARS
REGULATIONS THAT ADDRESS HEALTH
AND SAFETY ISSUES AT ELEAZAR. OF
WE BELIEVE WE ARE TESTIFIED LAST
YEAR AND CONTINUE TO BELIEVE
TODAY THAT MANY OF THOSE TITLE
FIVE REGULATIONS ACTUALLY
PROVIDE FAR MORE ROBUST.
PROTECTIONS OF THE CHILDREN. AND
THEN LASTLY ALSO TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT. THE ORIGINAL
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL A COMPONENT
OF THAT WAS ABOUT PROVIDING THE
FLEXIBILITY TO STREAMLINE THE
PROGRAM SO THAT WE COULD PROVIDE
GREATER ACCESS.
TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN THAT DID NOT PREVIOUSLY
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS.
CLEARLY WE WANT TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE THAT WE CAN TO ENSURE
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THOSE
CHILDREN.
I WE BELIEVE THAT THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS IS A CHIEF
TACKLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AMANDA DICKEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION I
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE.
I WANT TO ADDRESS TWO QUICK
POINTS ECHOING THE ACCESS ISSUE
WE REALLY DO FEEL LIKE THIS WILL
LEAD TO GREATER ACCESS BECAUSE
OF THE STREAMLINING THAT IT WILL
ALLOW FOR ELEAZAR WHO. WE KNOW
HOLD THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CONTRACTS WHEN IT COMES TO SEE
PRESCHOOL.
AND I THINK WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS ABOUT THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION ISSUES FOR SURE BUT
WE ALSO. AGREED WITH AND DID
RECOMMEND TO THE ALLEY A WORKER
AT THE ALLEY รณ WORK GROUP.
THAT THEY ADOPT THESE ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS THAT THEY INCLUDED
IN THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH
WOULD EXPEDITE THE PROCESS FOR
ADDRESSING PARENT COMPLAINTS AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROCESS
BEGINS WITHIN TEN DAYS AND ALLOW
PARENTS TO FOLLOW ANONYMOUSLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI LAURA MADNESS STARTED FORESEE
CINEMA.
I WANNA ECHO THE CONCERNS THAT
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
ADVOCATES HAVE.
MENTIONED HERE.
ALSO THAT.
WE NEED MORE INSPECTIONS FOR
ESPECIALLY THOSE YOUNG THREE
YEAR OLDS NOT LESS AND WE ARE
BUCKING THE NATIONAL TREND FOR
ANNUAL INSPECTIONS.
ALSO NOT ONLY OUR THREE YEAR
OLDS NOT NECESSARILY POTTY
TRAINED BUT THEY ARE NOT VERBAL
NECESSARILY SO THEY CANNOT
VERBALIZE HAVE THEIR ISSUES AND
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT.
PARENTS HAVE ACCESS TO ANY.
HISTORY OF COMPLAINTS.
OF A.
A FACILITY WHERE THEIR YOUNG
CHILDREN ARE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LAURIE
FURSTENFELD AND I AM A SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE CHILDCARE
LAW CENTER WE ECHOED THAT SAME
CONCERNS OF MANY OF. ON THE
OTHER E. C. E. ADVOCATES
REGARDING HEALTH AND SAFETY ARE
LATE TO FOCUS ON THEIR CURRENT
UNIFORM COMPLAINT SYSTEM. IF
THAT OUR PROCEDURE IF THIS IS
WHAT PARENTS ARE LEFT TO MOVING
FORWARD WE HIGHLY RECOMMEND
IMPROVING IT.
PERSONALLY REPRESENTING TWO
PARENTS IN THE PAST YEAR AND
HELPING THEM WRITING UNIFORM
COMPLETE IT'S A VERY OPAQUE.
DIFFICULT PROCESS TO GO THROUGH
PARENTS REALLY HAVE LITTLE
GUIDANCE AT BOTH LEVELS BOTH
MAKING COMPLAINTS TO THE SCHOOL
AND THEN TO. CD  ON SO I
WOULD HIGHLY RECOMMEND ON
IMPROVING THAT PROCESS IN MAKING
IT LESS BURDENSOME FOR PARENTS
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
MOTIVES KAI JACKSON WITH CITY
WHO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IDEA.
LIKE TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF
OUR COLLEAGUES FROM SUCCESS AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN THAT SAFETY
FOR MOST VULNERABLE KIDS OUR
YOUNGEST KIDS IN THE C. SETTINGS
OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY. OFFER
ELEAZAR A PARTICULARLY IN SAN
DIEGO WE CONTINUE TO. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
RECEIVING THE SEARCH SAFEST
ENVIRONMENTS TO RECEIVE
EDUCATION AND DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. ARE AND WE'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT TO
THE LA O. PROCESS WHICH WE
APPRECIATE. ARM WE WE.
SUPPORT THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE OF THE LA OR LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR CONVERSATIONS ON
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS SUCH
AS A FACILITIES RATIOS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
STRUCTURE YES TIES US QUICK
QUESTION HERE SADDAM MADE THIS
IMPOSSIBLE TO MISS BROWN MAYBE
SOMEONE ELSE ON THE PANEL. WHO
DESERTED ALLUDED TO THAT IS A
NUMBER PRESCHOOLS?
ACROSS THE STATE THAT MIGHT BE
UNSAFE PROBABLY THOUGH I THINK.
THEY SUGGESTED THAT ARE THAT
ARE.
THOSE THOSE THAT A RUNNER
ELEAZAR IS THAT TRUE THAT THE
BOOGIE MAN WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
A MINUTE DEFERRED AS THERE ARE
NONE THAT WHEN.
STILL AT WE ACTUALLY AND FOR THE
PRE SCHOOLS THAT ARE CALVINISTIC
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION MONITORS THROWS
THROUGH OUR TITLE FIVE
STANDARDS.
AND WE HAVE A STAFF
WHO GO OUT TO SITES AND LOOK
BOTH OUTSIDE HEALTH AND SAFETY
NOT ALL OF THE ELEMENTS OF TITLE
TWENTY TWO BECAUSE THAT'S A
DIFFERENT CODE. AND THEIR
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES BUT
THERE ARE ELEMENTS OF THAT WITH
END TITLE FIVE AS WELL AS
PROGRAM QUALITY SO ACTUALLY
LOOKING MORE AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE PROGRAM. AS
WELL AS PROGRAM INTEGRITY AND
THE INTERNAL CONTROLS AND HOW
THEY'RE USING THE FUNDS THAT
SORT OF THING.
SO IT'S NOT THE WILD WEST OUT
THERE THERE ARE BUILDING SAFETY
CODES.
YEAH CRACKED.
THERE ARE TO KEEP CHILDREN SAFE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THIS ISSUE WILL BE
HELD OPEN. AND WE WILL CONSIDER.
.
TAKE ACTION ARE LEAVING IT AS IT
IS LATER IN THE BUDGET PROCESS.
NEXT ISSUE IS ISSUED NUMBER
THREE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
RELATE TO. EARLY EDUCATION AND
AFTER SCHOOL.
PROGRAMS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
LAYO.
CD AND.
AND ON THIS ISSUE AGAIN THERE'S
NO PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE.
ON THE NEXT ISSUES ARE GOING TO.
TO OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
ON PROPOSALS FOR ISSUES NOT IN
THE BUDGET.
AS WELL AS.
.
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE.
CURRENTLY IN THE GOVERNOR.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET. THANK
YOU. BERMAN FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING BRIANNA FRIENDS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES OVER
FOUR POINT THREE BILLION FOR
CALIFORNIA'S EARLY LEARNING IN
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS.
THIS REPRESENTS AN EIGHT PERCENT
INCREASE OVER THE TOTAL TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT
ALLOCATION.
THESE AUGMENTATIONS ARE LARGELY
ATTRIBUTABLE TO FULL YOUR
IMPLEMENTATION OF ITEMS INCLUDED
IN THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
BUDGET ACTS.
INCLUDING INCREASES TO PROVIDE
EVERY EMBRACE IT RATES FALL THEY
STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS AS WELL AS
INCREASES IN HOW IT STAGE TWO
AND THREE COST OF CARE.
IN ADDITION THIS BUDGET INCLUDES
THE FINAL AUGMENTATIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN MULTI YEAR AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LOOK AT THE LEGISLATURE.
THESE AUGMENTATIONS INCLUDED TWO
POINT EIGHT PERCENT STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE INCREASE.
I A PERMANENT EXTENSION OF THE
REGIONAL MARKET WE EMBRACE AND
RATE HOLD HARMLESS INCLUDED IN
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
BUDGET ACT.
AND THE FINAL ROUND OF
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND
FULL DAY STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES ONE TIME INVESTMENT OF
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
BILLION PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND AND FORTY TWO POINT
TWO MILLION FEDERAL TANITH FOR
THE INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION PROGRAM.
THE INTENT OF THIS PROGRAM IS TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION IN SETTINGS
APPROPRIATE FOR ALL CHILDREN
AGED ZERO TO FIVE.
THIS PROGRAM WILL BE A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM WITH
PRIORITY GIVEN TO THOSE WITH A
DEMONSTRATED NEED FOR EXPANDED
ACCESS.
AS WELL AS APPLICANTS TO
REPRESENT A CONSORTIUM OF LOCAL
PARTNERS.
THESE GRANT FUNDS MUST BE USED
FOR ONE TIME INFRASTRUCTURE
COSTS SUCH AS COST OF EQUIPMENT
FACILITIES RENOVATIONS THAT AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. AND
WILL BE AVAILABLE OVER A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD.
THIS PROGRAM WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION BE OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION DIVISION AND THE EARLY
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT DIVISION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
GOOD MORNING SIR COURT HAS WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH THREE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SAW
LIMIT MY COMMENTS TO THESE
PROPOSALS THE FIRST IS THE.
THE FIRST IS TO INCREASE STATE
PRESCHOOL SLOTS THE SECOND WOULD
BE TO CREATE INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION GRANT IN
THIRD IS TO EXTEND THE ARMOR
HOLD HARMLESS.
WITH REGARD TO THE FIRST
PROPOSAL TO ADD STATE PRESCHOOL
SLOTS ON TO ELEAZAR ARKANSAS WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT LIMITING
SLOTS TO I LIAISE PRIMARILY
BECAUSE RECENT SLOTS ON. RECENT
THOUGHTS RELEGATES ARE NOT BEEN
FULLY UTILIZE CD HAS HAD TO RUN
MULTIPLE ROUNDS OF APPLICATIONS
TO FILL THE SLOTS AND OUTSIDE TO
USE ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY TO
ALLOCATE SLOTS THAT WERE
INTENDED TO BE FULL THEY SLOTS
FOR ELEAZAR. INTO PART THE SLOTS
FOR BOTH ELEAZAR NOT ONLY AIDS.
IN RECENT LAW INCREASES HAVE
BEEN EARMARKED TO PROPOSITION
NIGHT OF PROPER. HAD BEEN
EARMARKED TO ELOISE PRIMARY
PRIMARILY WITH THE INTENTION TO
USE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING.
STATE PRESCHOOL USE OF THE MIX
OF FUNDING SOURCES THAT'S REDUCE
THE STATE'S FLEXIBILITY TO AYE
FULL DAY SLOTS TO BOTH NON
ELEAZAR ELEAZAR. WERE LA FULL
DAY FLOCK THERE FUNDED ENTIRELY
PRINT FROM PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT OR NINE ELLIOTT FULL DAY
SLOTS ARE FUNDED WITH THE MAKES
A PROPOSITION NINETY AND NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. AND WE
RECOMMEND.
WE RECOMMEND FUNDING ALL STATE
PRESCHOOL PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT AND THIS WOULD RESULT IN
SHIFTING A PORTION A FULL DAY
STATE PRESCHOOL THAT'S FUNDED
WITH PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
INCH. WITH NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT INTO PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT WHICH WOULD GIVE
FLEXIBILITY TO THE STATE OF
DISTRIBUTE THOUGHTS TO ANY
INTERESTED PROVIDER. A THEN
MOVING FORWARD IF THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTERESTED IN
SUPPORTING MORE FULL DAY STATE
PRESCHOOL SLOTS TO MAKE
AVAILABLE TO BOTH NON LEN ALLEY
PROVIDERS.
WITH REGARD TO THE SECOND
PROPOSAL TO.
TO CREATE INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION CARD
EXPANSION RAT. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S INTEREST
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES IS LAUDABLE
BUT WE RECOMMEND REJECTING A
PROPOSAL AND AS A SIDE NOTE
THIS.
PROGRAM USES BOTH PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT AND.
ANTENNA FUNDING.
JUSTIN NO FEDERAL REGULATION
GENERALLY PROHIBIT THE USE OF
TEN OF FUNDS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
IT APPEARS UNLIKELY THAT CAN'T
IF ONE COULD BE USED FOR THE
FACILITY. RENOVATION PROPOSED
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
BUT PRIMARILY ARE CONCERNED IS
IN REGARDS THAT CD  RUNS
PROGRAMS TO FUND THE PROPOSED
PURPOSES SUCH AS THE PURPOSE IS
TO FIRST SUPPORT FACILITY NEEDS
A PER AND TO SUPPORT QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAMS.
AS AN ALTERNATIVE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD MODIFY
INCREASE.
INCREASE FUNDING TO THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO FURTHER
SUPPORT PROVIDERS.
FOR EXAMPLE THE CHILD CARE
FACILITIES REVOLVING PHONE
APPROACH WHERE PROVIDERS COULD
APPLY FOR INTEREST FREE LOANS
AND PURCHASE RENOVATED
FACILITIES. I'M WITHIN THIS
PROGRAM PROVIDERS ARE RESTRICTED
TO PURCHASING PORTABLE
FACILITIES AND PROVIDERS ARE NOT
USING THIS PROGRAM.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN NO
PROVIDERS APPLY FOR THESE FUNDS.
WHICH HURT MUCH CURRENTLY HOLD
OVER TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
AND AS AN ALTERNATIVE FOR THIS
PROGRAM THE LEGISLATURE COULD
MAKE A PORTION OF THIS PROGRAM
ON THE GRANT THEY COULD THEY
COULD OUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
THIS PROGRAM THEY COULD EXTEND
THE PAYMENT RIPARIAN. BROUGHT IN
THE ALLOWABLE USES SO THAT THIS
FUND COULD ADDRESS THE EXISTING
FACILITY MEANS.
A THAT IN TERMS OF THE TECH
TRAINING PURPOSES WE THINK ONE
TIME FUNDING TOWARDS THIS IS
UNLIKELY TO IMPROVE QUALITY
PROVE MEANT A QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT IN THIS AREA.
ON CD  RUNS ABOUT THIRTY
QUALITY PROOF IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAMS AND IF THE LEGISLATURE
WAS INTERESTED IN IT THEY'RE
DETERMINED THAT EXISTING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WASN'T.
INSUFFICIENT IT COULD REALLOCATE
EXISTING QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
FUNDING TO PRIORITIZE SPECIAL
RELATED. ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
RELATED TRAINING OR PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THIS PURPOSE.
AND WITH REGARD TO THE THIRD
PROPOSAL WHICH IS THE ARMOR HOLD
HARMLESS PROPOSAL WE RECOMMEND
THAT. THE LEGISLATURE ALLOW
EXISTING HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION
CAN SPOT EXPIRE AT THE END OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS AN WITH
CURRENT LAW.
WHEN THE STATE IS INCREASE RATES
IN RECENT YEARS THEY ARE
ACCOMPANIED BY TEMPORARY HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION SO THAT NO
PROVIDER RECEIVED. LESS THAN IT
RECEIVES PRIOR TO THE RATE
INCREASE TODAY THIS RESULTS IN
FUNDING DERIVED AND SLOT FUNDING
BEING DERIVED AND ONE OF FOR
SURVEYS. WE ESTIMATE THAT SIXTY
THREE PERCENT OF SLOTS ARE
FUNDED USING THE MOST RECENT
SURVEY.
TO DETERMINE THEIR RAY WHERE
THE REMAINING UNTIL JUNE TO THE
HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION THE
REMAINING THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT
OF SLOTS ARE FUNDED WITH RATES
DERIVE FROM PRIOR YOUR SURVEYS.
THIS SPECIFIC HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION DOES TWO THINGS TO THE
CHILD CARE MARKET THE FIRST IT
ALLOWS SOME FAMILIES ACCESS THE
LARGER SHARE THE MARKET OF THE
CHILD CARE MARKET THAN OTHERS.
AND THE SECOND REMEMBER IT THIS
REIMBURSES SOME CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WITHOUT RATES HIGHER
THAN THE SEVENTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE OF THE REGIONAL
MARKET. IN BY SAID EXTENDING THE
POLES CRIMES PROVISION THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL EXTEND THE
INEQUITIES IN ACCESS.
IN ACCESS AND REIMBURSEMENT
RATES ACROSS THE STATE.
SO RATHER BY EXTENDING THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER USING
THE PROPOSED AUGMENTATION WHICH
IS FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN
HUNDRED.
ALTERNATE PLYMOUTH ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT SLOTS USING THE MOST
RECENT COST ESTIMATES.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION BUT I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
BERMAN OF EDUCATION I'D FAIR
ENOUGH MARK AND I MET SO WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND I'M GONNA START WITH
THAT PRE SCHOOL EXPANSION AND
THEN GO ON TO THE EARLY I'D.
I THINK INCLUSIVE GRANT PROGRAM
SEVEN TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE MADE A MULTI YEAR
AGREEMENT CUT THE PRESCHOOL
PROMISED TO FIND A HUNDRED
MILLION OVER THREE YEARS TO
EXPAND QUALITY FISCAL. FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES USING PROP
NINETY EIGHT. AND NINE ALLEYWAYS
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO OPERATE
EITHER FULL DAY OR PER DAY CS PP
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM USING THOSE FUNDS WHILE
NINE ELEAZAR. ONLY RECEIVE THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING FOR
THE PART DAIS YES PP.
SO WE HAVE HAD WHAT I'M OVER
FINISHING UP OUR SECOND ROUND OF
THAT IN THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THE RFA WAS RESTRICTED
TO ELEAZAR. AND WE DID HAVE TO
RELEASE IT THREE TIMES THIS GOES
TO THE LA OWES RECOMMENDATION TO
ALLOW NON ELEAZAR TO OPERATE
STATE PRESCHOOL WITH. THAT AND
PROP NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS SO
THREE YOU RELEASES OF OUR FACE
IN ORDER TO EXPAND ALL OF THOSE
FUNDS.
THIS LAST TIME THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET WE
HAVE WE WERE I AM ABLE TO DO
BOTH NON. ELEAZAR AND ELEAZAR
AND PRIORITY FOR FULL DAY AND
PER DAY. WE ARE ABOUT TO RELEASE
OUR INFORMATION ON THAT THE
APPLICATION HAD BEEN EXTENDED
DUE TO THE FIRES AND MUD SLIDES
SO WE DID HAVE A DELAY AS WE
LIVE. APPLICANTS COMMAND WE DO
NOT THINK THAT WILL EXPAND ALL
THE DOLLARS AND SO THERE WILL BE
SOME STILL THERE THAT WILL LOOK
AT PUTTING BACK OUT AGAIN. AT
BUT WE HAVE HEARD AGAIN AND
AGAIN THAT THE NONO LIAISED
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
MORE AT THIS YES PP. SLOTS.
SAID THEN I'M GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE INCLUSIVE EARLY ADD
EXPANSION PROPOSAL AND WE WOULD
SAY THAT THIS PROPOSAL
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF ALL
OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
ENTERING THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM. TO BE IN THE MOST
INCLUSIVE AND SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENTS POSSIBLE WHICH IS
NOT ONLY CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
EARLY CHILDHOOD RESEARCH IT IS
ALSO THE FOUNDATION ON WHICH THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
EDUCATION ACT. IDA AS BELT
EDUCATING CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
ENVIRONMENTS WITH SAME AGE PEERS
WITHOUT DISABILITIES IS
DESCRIBED IN THE A. D. A.. AS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT AND HAVE A
LIFELONG IMPACT ON CHILDREN'S
FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES IMPROVED
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES. ACCESS FOR
PARTICIPATION AND ALL ASPECTS OF
SCHOOL LIFE AS WELL AS
MEANINGFUL COMMUNITY AND CAREER
LIFE THE RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS
THAT CHILDREN WHO DON'T HAVE THE
DISABILITY SO THERE IS.
NORMALS ELITE DEVELOPING PEERS
ALSO BENEFIT FROM THE FULL
INCLUSION PROGRAMS.
WE SEE THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO THAT FOR ALL
CHILDREN. AS WELL AS LOOKING AT
A WAY TO INCENTIVIZE PROGRAMS
THAT DO YOU HAVE CHILDREN IN
SPECIAL DAY CLASSROOMS THERE'S
SO THAT THEY WOULD INSTEAD
BECOME FULL INCLUSION MODELS AND
BE IN THE SAME. PROGRAMS WITH
OTHER PEERS.
SELF SUPPORT FOR THAT ONE.
AND THEN AND.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE ARMOR HOLD
HER LAST.
WE FELT THAT OUR PROGRAMS WITH
THAT SUBSIDIES RATES AND ALL OF
THOSE PIECES WOULD CONTINUE TO
BENEFIT FROM HAVING NOT AS THEIR
REIMBURSEMENT.
DEBORAH BROWN OF THE HAVE A
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT THE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS SINCE THAT IS
JUST PART OF THIS ITEM. HAVING
ON BEHALF OF AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS THAT THE SUPERINTENDENT
WAS APPRECIATIVE OF THAT
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS PROVIDED IN THE BUDGET
TO. INCREASE THE.
HOURLY ARE THAT THAT DAILY RATE
FOR THE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
AND AND ANYTHING CAN HEAR MORE
ABOUT THIS IN THE NEXT ITEM BUT
THERE CONTINUES TO BE A NEED TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL FUNDING. TO
INCREASE THEIR RATES NOT ONLY AS
THE MINIMUM WAGE IS GOING UP BUT
IS ALSO THE ACOSTA AT THE COST
OF LIVING IS GOING UP BUT IT
HASN'T BEEN ADJUSTED BEYOND THE
FIFTY MILLION SO. YOU KNOW YOU
HEAR HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT IN THE
NEXT ITEM BUT WE'D LIKE TO KNOW
OUR SUPPORT FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR AFTER SCHOOL.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE I DO HAVE A FEW
COMMENTS ON ON THESE ITEMS FIRST
WHILE ALREADY AFTER SCHOOL.
PROGRAMS I'D A BIG BELIEVER IN
SUPPORT OF OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
THEY HAVE TREMENDOUS JOB
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FROM
COMMUNICATIVE SLOT FORCED MEANT
EDUCATION GROUPS AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE MONEY IN THE
BUDGET WERE WERE TIED ON THE
GENERAL FUND. BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO NOTE DOWN BY MITCH THIS LAST
YEAR FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IT PROP SIXTY FOUR.
THE MARIJUANA MEASURE HE CAN'T
QUITE SEE THIS BUT HERE'S A
CAMPAIGN COMMERCIAL FROM PROP
SIXTY FOUR AND IT SAYS.
PROP SIXTY FOUR FUNDS AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS
THAT WAS THAT WAS THE REALLY THE
ONLY PROMISED TO THE VOTERS WHO
SAY ONE ATTACKS AND REGULATE
MARIJUANA.
AND THE REVENUE YET THAT THAT
THE THE HEADLINE WAS FUND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS SO. JUST WANT TO
ASK.
WHAT IS OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THINKING ABOUT WHEN?
SIXTY FOUR REVENUES WILL COME
FORWARD AND HOW WE WILL HOW WILL
WE.
MEMORIALIZE THIS PROMISE TO THE
ELECTORATE.
CHAU ACTED AFRAID AT MY MY
COLLEAGUES AT FINANCE ARE
ACTUALLY WORKING ON ON THAT ON
THAT ASSIGNMENT.
SIDE I'D HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOUR.
OKAY BUT JUST THAT POINT BUT
NOTED THAT SOUND WHEN IT DOES.
NOT COME BACK THAT THE REVENUE
PLAN WE.
EXPECTS
THAT THAT WE WILL TAKE IT INTO
CONSIDERATION THE PROMISE TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
OKAY AND THEN ALSO FOR THE EARLY
EDUCATION COMPONENT THAT WE'RE
GONNA HEAR. IN GREAT DETAIL NEXT
BUT BUT I WOULD NOTE THAT.
THAT THERE ARE NEW.
THAT THAT PIECE IS IN THE STATE
BUDGET HERE BUT JUST TO TO FOR
THE BIG PICTURE THIS IS NOTHING
NEW IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THESE
ARE.
COMMITMENTS FROM THE PRIOR
YEAR'S BUDGET AGREEMENT AND THAT
WE STILL KNOW THAT.
.
THERE ARE FAR AND.
PART TWO AND.
THEN THERE ARE THERE A LOT OF
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA FAMILIES THAT
ARE BET THAT ARE MISSING OUT
WITH AN OPTION YOU COULD EITHER
THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM HEAD
START OR TWO K. THE ENTER. OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM WITHOUT ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO BENEFIT AT THAT
THE MINIMUM OF ONE YEAR QUALITY
EARLY EDUCATION THAT'S A
CONTINUED PRIORITY.
AS MR JOBS THAT EARLIER FOR FOR
THE ASSEMBLY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE ON
THIS QUEST.
SO WITH THAT WE'LL GO NOW TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR.
AND FOCUS ON.
POSSIBLE INVESTMENTS EARLY
EDUCATION NUTRITION AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
AND THIS IS A AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE PUBLIC TO SHARE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE.
ON THESE ITEMS
.
YEAH.
WE HAD ONLY ONE ISSUE.
YEAH FROM SEVERAL.
MILLIMETERS.
YEAH.
OKAY AS WE GET ORGANIZED RIGHT
THERE JUST REMINDER AND ASKED
THE PUBLIC TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
TO. A ONE MINUTE OR LESS ONE
MINUTE OR LESS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
LEARNING AND THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION COALITION. AND WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TO DISCUSS OUR PROPOSA THIS
YEAR. AND AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THERE IS A STRONG OF A* LACK
OF INFANT TODDLER CARE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH LESS THAN
FOURTEEN PERCENT OF ZERO TO TWO
YEAR OLDS ACTUALLY HAVING ACCESS
TO CARE.
SO TO REMEDY THIS PROPOSAL ONE
OF THE REQUESTS THAT THE WITH
THE PER THE COALITION PROPOSES A
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT.
TO CREATE IMMEDIATE ACCESS AND
SPACE FOR THESE CHILDREN.
IN ADDITION WHERE PEROT
REQUESTING SUPPORTS TO REALLY
BUILD UP. OUR SYSTEM FOR OUR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
WERE REQUEST WE'RE REQUESTING
THAT THE INFANT TODDLER FACTOR
REFLECT THE CURRENT COST OF
CARE.
WE ARE REQUESTING THAT THAT TO
RE ESTABLISH THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT DAYS FOR A TITLE
FIVE CENTERS SO THAT THEY'RE
PREPARED TO START SERVING THESE
CHILDREN. THAT WE ARE ALSO
REQUESTING START UP FUNDS SO
THAT CENTERS CAN CONVERT TO
CLASSROOMS OR OPEN CLASSROOMS
BECAUSE INFANTS AND TODDLERS
HAVES UNIQUE NEEDS THAT ARE
REQUIRED. UP IN ORDER TO SERVE
THEM.
FINALLY WE DO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION GRANT BUT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR EDUCATORS FOR
EDUCATION FOR YOUNG CHILDRENS
DEFINITION OF INCLUSION BE
INCLUDED. IN THAT PROGRAM WE
THINK THAT IT IS A BROAD
DEFINITION THAT INCLUDES
BASICALLY. ANY DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAY OF THAT A CHILD MAY HAVE.
LASTLY WE ALSO ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER FUNDING AT THE STATE
CHILD CARE INITIATIVE PROJECT
AND THE OUR IN OUR DATABASE UP
POTENTIALLY WITH ONE TIME OR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT FUNDS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
TIGHTENING MICHELETTI CULVER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION I SUPPORT ALL THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY.
COLLEAGUE MONIQUE RAM ELSE I
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THE NEED FOR
A HUNDRED THOUSAND VOUCHERS
SLOTS.
THESE ARE FOR WORKING FAMILIES
CURRENTLY WE HAVE LESS THAN
THREE PERCENT OF OUR HIGH
QUALITY CENTERS OFFER EVENING
AND WEEKEND CARE YET THE
FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE THE
WORKING POOR. THEY NEED THAT HAS
THE MINIMUM.
WE ALSO ARE ASKING FOR FIFTY
MILLION IN.
ONE TIME MONIES. TO.
UPDATE OUR SYSTEMS SO.
CURRENTLY WE ARE STILL UNABLE
TO IMPLEMENT FULLY THE TWELVE
MONTH INCOME ELIGIBILITY BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE CLEAR DIRECTION
YET TO DO THIS.
ON THAT NOTE WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THE SLACK THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ABOUT STARTING
CONTRACTS IN OCTOBER TWO
REFLECTING GIVE CD TIME IN THE
FIELD TIME TO WORK TOGETHER TO
HAVE A SEAMLESS AND.
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THEN.
WHEN THEM FINALLY ON THE LA A
SPOTS WE APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
MADE BY THE EL AT THE LA AUTO.
EN ABOUT SLOTS GOING TO ELEAZAR
WHAT WE WOULD RECOMMEND ALSO IS
CONSIDERATION THERE IS THAT
WITHIN THIRTY TO SIXTY DAYS
STEFANELLI A HAS DETERMINED TO
DO IN PARTNERSHIP. IN
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION WENT AND SPENT
WITH ELLIOTT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CANDOR HARRIS WITH
CHILD ACTION.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
COALITION.
AND.
A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
SO YOUR STAFF COMMENTS WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH CHANGING THE
CITY CONTRACT YEAR AS WELL AS
CHANGES RECOMMENDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE RATES WERE
LOOKING AT THOSE ARE PROPOSALS
AND HAVE SOME SERIOUS QUESTIONS.
SO WE'D LIKE TO BE A PART OF
THIS QUESTION GOING FORWARD WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND THE PARTNER
FINANCE AND MAKE SURE THE
CHANGES.
IF ANY ARE MADE WORK FOR BOTH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
PROGRAMS INVOLVED.
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE OF ARAGON ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE LOS ANGELES WE
SUPPORT THE EASY COALITIONS
BUDGET REQUEST CALIFORNIA'S MADE
PRODUCT PROGRESS ON EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OLDER CHILDREN
TO ATTEND PRESCHOOL AND
TRADITIONAL KINDERGARTEN. AND
NOW IS THE TIME FOR THE STATE TO
FOCUS ITS ATTENTION ON OUR
YOUNGEST MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN DURING THESE. FIRST
VITAL YEARS INCREASING ACCESS TO
INFANTILE THEIR CARE WITH THE
ONE BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
CHILDCARE SPACES IS THE MOST
IMMEDIATE WAY TO HELP. ADDRESS
THE SEVERE SHORTAGE IN OUR
SYSTEM.
I WE ALSO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO CREATE THE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM.
AND REQUEST A SIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATION TO THE ONE TIME
FUNDING PROPOSED FOR THE PROGRAM
TO SUPPORT FACILITIES EQUIPMENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AS WELL
AS OTHER QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS
ACOSTA OR MAKES DELIVERY SYSTEM.
WE ALSO REQUEST ALLOWING THESE
ONE TIME FUNDS TO BE ALLOCATED
AND SPENT OVER A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD.
ALSO WANT TO ECHO MONIQUE
RAMOS'S COMMENTS ABOUT USING THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR THE
EDUCATION OF YOUNG CHILDREN'S
DEFINITION OF. EARLY TELL
INCLUSION FOR THE PROGRAM THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT
THE EASY COALITION PROPOSAL TO
IMPROVE CHILD CARE ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES BY MAKING
CRITICAL ON SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS AND A CHILD CARE
SPACES. WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
EXPANDING INFANT TODDLER CARE.
PURSE I CALIFORNIANS TO
HIGHLIGHT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED REALLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
CLASSROOM START UP FUNDS THAT
PROVIDERS CAN BEGAN CONVERTING
EXISTING CLASSROOMS. INTO
APPROPRIATE INCLUSIVE INFANT
PRESCHOOL CLASSROOMS LICCARDO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATURE ON THE SCHOOL.
BUS ONE HIGHLIGHT THE RESOURCE
CENTER FOR ON THAT EXTRA
POSITIVE SPAN AND ENHANCE THE
CONSUMER EDUCATION DATABASE THIS
COMMITTEE HAS HEARD MANY TIMES
ABOUT THE NEED FOR SYSTEMS
ALIGNMENT ACROSS THE STATE'S
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. NOTHING ANY FUNDING TO
THE DATABASE IS A GREAT FIRST
STEP TOWARDS THE SCHOOL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI TRACY PATTERSON WITH
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
WE HAVE TWO DISTINCT AND
SEPARATE PROPOSALS LISTED ON THE
AGENDA I'M GOING TO ADDRESS ONE
OF THEM ARE EARLY CHILDHOOD
COALITION PARTNERS WILL JUST THE
OTHER. A SPECIFIC TO ONE OF THEM
RELATED TO AFTER THE BELL SCHOOL
BREAKFAST FOR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS
THIS IS A REQUEST TO EXTEND THE
ONETIME AUGMENTATION THAT THIS
COMMITTEE. PROVIDED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO PROVIDE
TARGETED GRANTS TO HIGH POVERTY
SCHOOLS TO EXPAND BREAKFAST
AFTER THE BELL PROGRAMS.
AND THANKS YOUR EFFORTS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN CD
AWARDED OVER ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY SCHOOL SITE SERVING
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED KIDS IN THE PREVIOUS
YEAR. THE AUGMENTATION LAST ON
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WAS FOR TWO
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS THERE HAS
BEEN CLOSE TO FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS REQUESTED FUNDS FOR THAT
GRANT FUND SO THE DEMAND HAS
GREATLY EXCEEDED THE SUPPLY. I'M
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
EXTEND THAT AUGMENTATION AS A
ONE TIME FUNDING REQUEST THAT
COULD BE USED OVER A PERIOD OF
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS TO ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO EXPAND HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL UP BREAKFAST AFTER
BILL PROGRAMS. THAT SUPPORT
STUDENT LEARNING AND MITIGATE
CHILD POVERTY THANK YOU.
THIS CHAIRMAN DUCK MCFETRIDGE ON
BEHALF OF NO KID HUNGRY A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
AIMED AT. IT ENDING CHILDHOOD
HUNGER.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE ONE
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION IN
THE BUDGET.
.
AND THAT THE PERSON COMMITTED A
SPORT THAT I'M PETITIONS.
GOOD MORNING OUT COOL ACCOUNTING
WITH THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION AMERICAN STROKE
ASSOCIATION.
I'M PLEASED TO TALK ABOUT OUR
PROPOSAL FOR HEALTHY EARLY CARE.
IN WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF I'M THE CHILDCARE
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL NETWORKS
AS WELL AS A CHILD CARE ALLIANCE
OF LA. ON THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION REALLY LOOKED AT.
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE CDC
THE SURGEON GENERAL THAT SAID
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
USE.
LOOK AT.
EARLY CHILD CARE.
FOR A BUILDING HEALTHY HABITS
ON TO SEND OUR KIDS ON THAT PATH
AND SO ON WE LOOKED AT A OF A
MODEL THAT WAS SIGNED BY THE LA
DEPARTMENT.
THE LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THAT REALLY WORKED WITH
PROVIDERS TO OUR FOCUS ON A
NUTRITION AND AGE APPROPRIATE
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY AND LIMITING
SCREENTIME ON THEIR DATE
RECEIVED A GRANT FROM OFFERS
FIVE TO WORK ON THIS AND THEY
HAD A REALLY POSITIVE RESULTS.
WITH PROVIDER KNOWLEDGE IN
IMPLEMENTATION REALLY SETTING
OUR KIDS UP FOR SUCCESS TO HAVE
THOSE THOSE I'M HEALTHY HABITS
AS THEY GROW UP. AND SO ON YOU
KNOW WE'RE ASKING FOR ONE TIME
ASK OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS ONTO
FLOW TO THEIR.
RESOURCEFUL NETWORKS I WAS A
GRANT PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED ON PROVIDERS WHO ARE
SERVING KIDS WERE LOW.
FROM LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE
LOCATED LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND THIS WILL REALLY SET OUR
CHILDREN UP.
FOR TO BE ON HEART HEALTHY AS A
CORRUPT AND LIFE AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
HI MY NAME IS CARE PROVIDERS TO
MEET THE
NUTRITIONAL NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE AND
CALIFORNIA CAN HELP WE'RE
REQUESTING FUNDING TO REIMBURSE
FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDERS. AND
CHILDCARE CENTERS AT THE SAME
RATE THAT THE STATE CURRENTLY
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS TO
SUPPLEMENT THAT THE COST OF
SERVING HEALTHY MEALS TO
CHILDREN. FOR DECADES CALIFORNIA
TOOK THIS APPROACH OF
SUPPLEMENTING THE COSTS OF
SERVING HEALTHY MEALS TO LOW
INCOME CHILDREN IN CHILDCARE BUT
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AT THE
HEIGHT OF THE RECESSION THAT
FUNDING WAS CUT IN THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN LOS ACCESS TO HEALTHY
MEALS. SENSE THAT CUT WAS MADE
TODAY ARE CITY ITS FINANCIAL
OUTLOOK IS IN A MUCH BETTER
PLACE AND IT'S TIME TO BRING
BACK WHAT WE KNOW WORKS WITH THE
STUNNING THE STATE CAN HELP
YOUNG CHILDREN. ACCESS AN EXTRA
SNACK EVERYDAY OR MAKE SURE THAT
CHILDREN HAVE A DINNER AT LEAST
ONCE A WEEK IF THEIR PARENTS ARE
WORKING LATE. FOR JUST A SMALL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING IF WE CAN GO A
LONG WAY TO ALSO HELP FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS. WHO ARE
CUTTING INTO THEIR OWN LIMITED
BUDGETS TO SERVE THE CHILDREN IN
THEIR CARE THINK THAT YOU?
HELLO MY NAME IS ARTISTIC PARA
AND I'M HERE TO.
REPRESENT FAMILY RESOURCE WE
FOUGHT IN STAFF WORKING COUNTY
WHICH SERVER ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE LIKES TALK HERE
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND ALSO.
INCLUDING THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
ONE HERE IN SACRAMENTO AREA OF
FORTUNE THE OPERATORS WERE NOT
ABLE TO ATTEND TODAY TO THIS
HEARING BECAUSE THEY'RE THE SALT
OPERATORS OF THEIR BUSINESS. AND
HAVE TO ATTEND TO THE KIDS IF
THEY COULD ATTEND THERE WOULD
TELL YOU THAT THEY WANT TO SERVE
HEALTHY MEALS BUT LIMITED
RESOURCES AND HIGH COSTS MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO MEET THEIR
NUTRITIONAL. NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN THEIR CARE MANY
REPORTERS ARE LIKE IN THE SOUTH
ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT RELY ON THE
STAFF PROGRAM TO FEED THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES THAT THEY
PROVIDERS ARE OFTEN CUT. DIRT
FAMILY.
FOOD BUDGETS TO FEED THE
CHILDREN IN THE CARE BECAUSE
THEY KNOW SOME OF THE CHILDREN.
THE ONLY SOLID MEAL. THAT THEY
WOULD RECEIVE IN THEIR CARE SO
THE STATE CUT FUNDING IS BACK IN
TWENTY TAUGHT MANY THE
PARTICIPANTS TO DROP THE FOOD
PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY
COULD NOT AFFORD IT. MAJORITY
ARE LOW INCOMES IN RURAL AREAS.
REIMBURSED IN THE TALKING.
PROVIDERS FOR SERVING HEALTHY
MEALS WILL GO A LONG WAY BOTH
PROVIDING FOODS TO YOUNG KIDS
BUT ALSO SUPPORTING THE.
BY A BODY OF THE CHILD CARE
WORKFORCE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M CHRISTINE SMITH
ON THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
NUTRITION SERVICES FOR
NEIGHBORHOOD HOUSES ASSOCIATION
SAN DIEGO. REGISTERED DIETITIAN
AND ALSO AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE
MEMBER OF THE CHILD IT UP CARE
FOOD PROGRAM ON TABLE. AND.
AYE OF. WORK FOR NEIGHBORHOOD
HOUSE ASSOCIATION WHICH SERVES
SIX THOUSAND HEAD START AND
EARLY HEAD START CHILDREN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY.
MY DEPARTMENT NUTRITION
SERVICES DELIVERS AND PREPARES
ONE MILLION MEALS EVERY YEAR.
IN TWENTY TWELVE AS YOU'VE
HEARD THE FUNDING FOR THE STATE
FUNDING FOR MALE REIMBURSEMENTS
WAS CUT.
AS A RESULT MY AGENCY LOST
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN JUST
ONE YEAR.
WE'VE SCRAMBLE TO RAISE MONEY
BY.
FUNDRAISING IN WRITING GRANTS
BUT THAT'S NOT GUARANTEED MONEY.
AS YOU KNOW.
THE STATE REQUIRES US TO SERVE
A HEALTHY MEALS WE FOLLOW THE
CHILD INTO A CURFEW PROGRAM. THE
MALE PATTERN HAS CHANGED THIS
YEAR IN OCTOBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WE HAVE SINCE THEN WE'VE BEEN
REQUIRED TO SERVE EVEN HEALTHIER
INGREDIENTS TO OUR CHILDREN. BUT
THE COST FOR THE YET A
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND NOT KEEP
PACE WITH THAT. ON AND THAT IS
WHY WE NEED THE TWENTY THREE
CENTS PER MEAL TO BE REINSTATED
THINKING.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS KEN HACKED NAM THE
POLICY DIRECTOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
NUTRITION POLICY INSTITUTE.
NPR ENGAGES IN RESEARCH TO
STRENGTHEN POLICY.
OUR FOCUS IS ON THE FEDERAL FOOD
PROGRAMS LIKE THE CHILD ADULT
CARE FOOD PROGRAM. WHICH SERVE
YOUNGER CHILDREN.
STATE NATIONAL SURVEYS SHOW THAT
MOST AMERICANS CONSUME FAR FEWER
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES.
FOR THAT I JERRY GUIDELINES SAY
THE SHOULD.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY HARMFUL AT
THE YOUNG AGES WHEN CHILDREN ARE
GROWING RAPIDLY WHEN THEIR
BRAINS ARE DEVELOPING. AND WHEN
THEY'RE FORMING TASTE
PREFERENCES AND DIETARY HABITS
THAT WILL LAST A LIFETIME.
UNFORTUNATELY FRUIT AND
VEGETABLES ARE RELATIVELY
EXPENSIVE FOODS.
FOR THE NEARLY ONE QUARTER OF
CALIFORNIA'S YOUNG CHILDREN WHO
LIVE IN POVERTY.
THESE ARE LIKELY TO BE MISSING
FROM THE FAMILY DIET.
THE FEDERAL CHILD ADULT CARE
FOOD PROGRAM HELPS MAKE UP THIS
DEFICIENCY.
BUT PARTICULARLY IN A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA THE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT DOES NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH.
WITH A TWENTY THREE CENTS PER
MEAL BEING REQUESTED IN THIS
ITEM.
A CHILD CARE CENTER COULD SERVE.
CARROTS.
APPLE'S.
ORANGES ALL. GROWN IN CALIFORNIA
SO THE FARMERS WILL BE HAPPY.
IN MAKE A CHILD THAT MUCH
HEALTHIER.
WITH SO MANY YOUNG CHILDREN
FACING POVERTY WE NEED TO ACT
EARLY.
SET OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS UP FOR
A LIFETIME OF BETTER HEALTH AND
SUCCESS.
THANKS A LOT.
SURE.
YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS BRENDAN TWO
IT ON BEHALF OF CAN DANGLE WHERE
A LARGE PROVIDER SERVING OVER
FOUR THOUSAND CHILDREN. IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA NINETY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE CHILDREN WE
SERVE.
RECEIVE SUBSIDIZED CARE
I AM. AND WE KNOW OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED AT THAT TIME PROVIDING
HEALTHY MEALS A NUTRITION
NUTRITIOUS MEALS TO CHILDREN CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE BOTH
PHYSICALLY AND ACADEMICALLY. AND
SO WE SEE.
YOU KNOW BETTER OUTCOMES
BECAUSE OF THAT AND.
.
WE ALSO WE MEET THE STANDARDS
THAT WE GET SOME FUNDING FROM
THE AND FROM THE CHILD AND ADULT
CARE FOOD PROGRAM AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL.
AND AT BUT EVEN WITH THAT WE
STRUGGLE TO MAKE IT WORK BECAUSE
I KIDDING OPERATES IN THE BAY
AREA WHICH IS A HIGH COST
REGION.
WE ARE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE
OUR OWN KITCHEN.
THAT'S ONE OF THE WAYS WE MAKE
IT WORK BUT YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
WE'RE ONLY REIMBURSED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL A DOLLAR SEVENTY
FIVE FOR BREAKFAST THREE TWENTY
THREE FOR LUNCH. AND SO.
.
YOU KNOW.
TO MAKE ALL THAT WORK THAT GOES
INTO FOOD PREPARATION.
IT IT ALSO GOES INTO THEIR
FACILITIES COSTS TRAVEL COSTS
RELATED TO GETTING THE FOOD
AROUND OF THE DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS IN AND GETTING THE
FOOD THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND SO ON YOU KNOW WE STRUGGLE
TO MAKE IT WORK AND AND WE WE
KNOW THAT WE COULD I DO MORE.
AND.
AND DO RIGHT IN BE MAKING A
BETTER INVESTMENT IN OUR
CHILDREN BY PROVIDING THIS AT
FUNDING TO OUR.
YET YOUNGEST LEARNERS THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING JEFF DAVIS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL
NETWORK.
.
I'M HERE TO.
JUST PROVIDE SOME INFORMATION
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS OVER FOUR
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED ASUS
PROGRAM SERVING FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND. CHILDREN AND YOUTH
DAILY QUE.
QUE THROUGH NINE I'M TODAY
YOU'RE DISCUSSING THE ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IT'S BEEN SHOWN
THAT.
.
CONSISTENT PARTICIPATION AN
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM CAN CLOSE
MATH ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
BETWEEN LOW INCOME AND HIGH
INCOME.
CHILDREN BY FIFTH GRADE.
THEY HAVE ALL SORTS OF ACADEMIC
AND COMMUNITY BENEFITS PRO
SOCIAL OUTCOMES
I'M AND IN FACT INVESTMENT IN
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS YIELD
COMMUNITY BENEFIT AND AND RESULT
AND ACTUAL FISCAL SAVINGS. I'M
THESE PROGRAMS ARE STRUGGLING AS
A RESULT OF FLAT FUNDING
INCREASE COST OF LIVING AN
INCREASED MINIMUM WAGE SO WE
SUPPORT AN INCREASE OF SEVENTY
SIX POINT THREE MILLION.
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS AND OF
COURSE DO YOU ALSO SUPPORT.
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON HOW
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR IN THE
ADULT USE OF RECREATIONAL
MARIJUANA AND THOSE TAX REVENUES
CAN FURTHER SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS
IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
PATRICK MORE TEAR AND I'M WITH
FIGHT CRIME INVEST IN KIDS AND
MISSION READINESS. WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER FOUR HUNDRED
PLEASE CHIEF SHERIFFS DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND VICTIMS OF
VIOLENCE.
AS WELL AS RETIRED MILITARY
LEADERS GENERALS AND ADMIRALS.
WE WANT TO. SAY THAT WE SUPPORT.
INCREASED FUNDING FOR EARLY
EDUCATION.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE LAST YEAR AFTER SCHOOL
FUNDING.
BUT RECOGNIZE THAT MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE WE SUPPORT AS JEFF SAID.
ABOUT SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE THIS YEAR AND TO ALSO
EXPLORE.
.
DIVERSIFIED FUNDING THROUGH
PROP SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LA LA CORNISH
CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORK WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION COALITIONS
ASK FOR A BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT AND EARLY EDUCATION.
I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF PIECES OF THAT ASK.
THE FIRST BEING THE CHILD CARE
INITIATIVE PROJECT WHICH BEGAN
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND IS
CEMENTED IN AT CODE. AND SERVES
EVERY COUNTY IN THE CALIFORNIA
THROUGH OUR MEMBER AGENCIES.
AND MOST.
CHILDREN ZERO TO THREE ARE CARED
FOR IN FAMILY CHILDCARE OR
FAMILY FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR CARE.
AND THAT'S WHEN MOST OF BRING
DEVELOPMENT OCCURS AS WELL.
THESE PROVIDERS FACE LONG HOURS
ISOLATION IT'S OFTEN ONE
PROVIDER WITH EIGHT CHILDREN AND
THEY NEED SUPPORT AND THE
CHILDCARE INITIATIVE PROJECT CAN
OFFER THAT FOR THEM.
THE SUPPLY OF LICENSED FAMILY
CHILD CARE HAS BEEN DECLINING
EVER SINCE THE RECESSION. THE
CHILDCARE INITIATIVE PROJECT
LAST YEAR WAS ABLE TO RECRUIT
AND TRAIN OVER FIVE THOUSAND
PROVIDERS.
THERE'S AT LEAST ONE STAFF
PERSON IN EVERY COUNTY THAT CAN
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO THESE FOLKS
TO FOR THE MOST PART. DECIDED TO
STAY HOME WITH KIDS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NURTURES AND NOT
BUSINESS PEOPLE. WITH BUSINESS
PRACTICES SUPPORT WITH THE
LICENSING PROCESS IN BASIC CHILD
DEVELOPMENT INFORMATION.
THE OTHER PIECE OF THE ASK THAT
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU IS
WITH FAMILY FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR
CARE SOMETIMES THEY'LL CHOOSE TO
COME OVER TO FAMILY TALK ABOUT
NOT ALWAYS. WE'D LIKE TO SEE
THEIR HOURLY RATE BEING CREASED
TO SEVENTY PERCENT OF THE FAMILY
CHILDCARE RATE. CURRENTLY
THEY'RE MAKING LESS THAN THREE
DOLLARS AN HOUR CARING FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN. THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CAM LEWIS
REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW AND WE
ON SAY WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE DC
COALITION ONE BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET INVESTMENT. I'M TO EXPAND
AND THE NEED UNMET NEED A CHILD
CARE ESPECIALLY FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS.
WE REALLY SUPPORT EXPANDING.
ARE SHOVEL READY.
CHILD CARE SPACES AS WELL AS
INVESTMENTS TO BUILD UP OUR
STATE CAPACITY TO SERVE ELIGIBLE
INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
SPECIFICALLY INCREASING THE
INFANT TODDLER FACTOR AND RE
ESTABLISHING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT DAYS FOR TITLE FIVE
PROFESSIONALS.
I'M PROGRAMS AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THEIR SEVERE SHORTAGE OF
PHYSICAL SPACE TO SERVE THIS
YOUNG POPULATION. AND WE SUPPORT
STARTUP GRANTS THAT WILL
PROVIDE.
I WAS THE PROVIDERS WITH THEIR
ON MATT ONE TIME NEEDS TO REALLY
CONVERT ROOMS TO SERVE INFANTS
AND TODDLERS THINK IS MUCH.
GOOD MORNING TEMPERATURES FOR
CHILD THREE SIXTY FORMALLY LOS
ANGELES UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL.
WE SUPPORT THE ECA COALITIONS
ASK.
ALSO ONE OF THE EMPHASIZE THE.
RATE FACTOR FOR DIFFERENT
DOLLARS.
TEN YEARS AGO WHEN WE LOOKED AT
PUTTING OF SLOTS OUT NO
PROVIDERS RESPONDED BECAUSE THE
INADEQUATE RATES WITHOUT AN
ADJUSTMENT. AND MANY CONTRACTORS
RETURNING A CONTRACT BACK.
YOU CAN'T PENCIL.
BUT ZERO TWO ONE ZERO TO SIX
RATIO AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS
THAT GO ALONG WITH FAMILY
BABIES.
AND PROFESSIONAL ALTMAN IS SO
IMPORTANT HAVE DONE THAT FOR
MANY YEARS.
AND WITHOUT DOING THAT WE'VE GOT
STAFF THAT.
AREN'T TRAINED TO HANDLE THE
POPULATION WERE TRYING TO BUILD
OUT HERE WRITTEN IN THIS ASK.
SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MORNING BEVERLY YOU WITH ETW
ASKS ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY.
WE SUPPORT THE C. COALITION
PROPOSAL FOR A BILLION DOLLARS
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS AS WELL AS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EARLY
EDUCATORS.
WE SUPPORT CALIFORNIA OR ARE
NETWORKS REQUEST FOR ONETIME
FUNDING FOR THE CONSUMER
EDUCATION WEBSITE AND DATABASE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
TO INCREASE LICENSE EXEMPTION OR
LICENSE EXAM. PROVIDER RATES TO
MAKE SURE THAT LICENSING SOME
PROVIDERS CAN STAND BUSINESS AND
CONTINUE TO SERVE CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN.
AND ALSO WE WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
BUDGET SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
LANGUAGE TO DEVELOP AN
ELECTRONIC TIME SHE PROCESS SO
THAT FAMILIES HOW CARE PROVIDERS
CAN BE PAID ON TIME.
FINALLY WE SUPPORT THE THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY.
HELLO MY NAME IS KEITH HERE AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE TARGET
EXCELLENCE PROGRAM ALSO A
STEERING COMMITTEE OF THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BLACK SHALL
LEGACY CAMPY.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
EXTENDED FUNDING FOR THE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM ASUS
AND I WANT TO. POINT OUT THAT
THIS CREATES A SAFE SPACE IN
AREAS WHERE THERE IS MAJOR
CHRONIC STRESS MIKE GAVE YOU AN
ATTACHMENT ON PAGE ONE THROUGH
FOUR TALKS ABOUT THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
AND ALICE THAT IT A LOW THAT OUR
PARENTS AND OUR STUDENTS CARRY
ON WE DID A SURVEY.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
YOUTH H. PROGRAM QUALITY
ASSESSMENT IN OVER NINETY
PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS FELT
THAT THE APPS SCHOOL PROGRAMS
PROVIDES A SAFE ENVIRONMENT. AND
A SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
ON THE BASIS PROGRAMS ALSO
IMPROVE ATTENDANCE AND REDUCE
SUSPENSIONS NOT PAGE FIVE IT
GAVE YOU A DOCUMENT FROM THE
THOMAS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WHICH SHOWS AN EXPERIMENTAL
CONTROL GROUP STUDY WHICH SHOWS
ATTENDANCE AND SUSPENSION RATES
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE IN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS WHO
ARE NOT AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
AND LASTLY ON THE PROGRAMS
INCREASE OUR PROJECT BASED
LEARNING WHICH CREATES A DEEPER
LEVEL OF LEARNING. BECAUSE YOU
LEARN BY DOING MUCH QUICKER THAN
RECITING REMEMBERING THINGS
AND SECONDLY IT ALSO INCREASES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR POSITIVE
SCHOOL CONNECTIONS FOR STUDENTS
AND PARENTS. IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH EQUITY FOR FAMILIES NOT
ONLY OUR STUDENTS BUT APPEARANCE
BECAUSE WE SEE OUR PARENTS
EVERYDAY AND SO WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTS SUCH AS
FITNESS. DIETS
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL ON CONTACTS
AND LASTLY INCREASES THE
ECONOMIC VITALITY OF THE
STRUGGLING COMMUNITIES BY
PROVIDING FREE CHILDCARE WHICH
EQUATES TO. TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER PARENT PER YEAR
BASED ON FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR
AND ALSO ALLOWS PARENTS TO WORK
LONGER HOURS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TO THE SOLEMN JAVA
TO THE GASTROPODS CALIFORNIA
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE EASY
COALITIONS UP BUDGET ASK.
SPECIFICALLY.
GIVEN THAT THE STATE REVENUES.
ARE HIGHER THAN EXPECTED.
WE BELIEVE THAT OUR LITTLE
BABIES NEED TO BE PART OF THE
STATE'S WELL BEING. MERELY
KEEPING A PROMISE FROM THE PAST
TWO YEARS. THREE YEARS IS NOT
ENOUGH.
OTHER THE STATE REALLY NEEDS TO
GO BAG OF AS IN A ONE BILLION
DOLLAR BAKE. AZUSA REPORT THAT.
.
OF FOR INSTANCE OUR ADDRESS A
PROJECT RECENTLY DID A STUDY OF
AN INFANT TODDLERS IN OUR AND
FOR EXAMPLE JUST WITHIN LA
COUNTY ALONE. OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS FAMILY CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
HAVE EXPERIENCED A DECREASE IN
THEIR LICENSE CAPACITY BY
SEVENTEEN PERCENT SO FOR
INSTANCE THERE WHERE I'M SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED ODD LICENSE CARE
PROVIDERS. OF CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
AND INTO.
BY TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN OUT IN
MARCH THAT WENT DOWN TO ABOUT
SIX THOUSAND SO THERE'RE AT THE
STATE REALLY NEEDS TO INVEST IN
OUR OUR INFANT TODDLER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN MAKING THIS BILLION
DOLLAR ASK A REALITY THAT YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY MUST FOR
REVERSING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS.
ONE VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
INCREASE IN THE SUPPLEMENTARY
FOR MEALS AND KEY TO TWELVE AND
A CHILD CARE HOMES AND ALSO ONE
OUTLANDER SUPPORT TO AND
CONTINUING THE FUNDING FOR THE
AFTER THE BELL GRANTS.
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
WANNA.
VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION'S
PROPOSAL TO.
PROVIDE TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
GRANTS TO CREATE A HEALTHIER
ENVIRONMENT SOME CHILDCARE AND
THEN CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE ACES
PROPOSAL SO THANK YOU.
DO NEED A STRONG RUN AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILD CARE
ALLIANCE OF LOS ANGELES IN THE
CHILDCARE RESOURCE CENTER. AS A
MEMBER OF WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE E. C. E. COALITION A BUDGET
ASK IN PARTICULAR.
WE SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF THE
CHILDCARE SLOTS IT'S THE NEXT
STEP. ARE IN THE PROCESS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
SUPPORTING WITH INCREASED
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND AND
STATE MEDIAN INCOME LEVEL
CHANGES. ON IN PARTICULAR WANTED
TO POINT OUT THAT IN LA COUNTY
ALONE ONLY ABOUT FIFTEEN PERCENT
OF THE CHILDREN ARE CURRENTLY
BEING SERVED.
.
THERE ARE SIXTEEN NINE HUNDRED
CHILDREN BEING SERVED IN THE
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAM WITH
FORTY SIX THOUSAND CHILDREN.
ELIGIBLE AND WAITING ON THE
WAITING LIST IN LA COUNTY. ARE
IN SAN BERNARDINO IT'S EVEN
LOWER ABOUT EIGHT PERCENT WITH
ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED CHILDREN
BEING SERVED AND ALMOST THIRTEEN
THOUSAND WAITING FOR SERVICES.
IN ADDITION WE SUPPORT THE
INFANT TODDLER.
RATE ADJUSTMENT FACTORS THE
REESTABLISHMENT OF THE.
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT DAYS
AND THE CHILD CARE CENTER
STARTUP FUNDS A TO INCREASE
ACCESSIBILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
AND AVAILABILITY OF INFANT AND
TODDLER CARE WHICH IS REALLY OUT
GREATLY NEEDED.
AND ADDITIONALLY.
WITH THE USE OF ONE TIME ONLY
FUNDS AND QUALITY DOLLARS WE
URGE FUNDING FOR THE CHILDCARE
INITIATIVE PROJECT. THE CONSUMER
EDUCATION DATABASE AS WELL AS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VERONICA WHAT THEN
AYE PART INVOICE I LEAVE IT.
THERE MUDDING CLUNKY.
AND I NEED DATA HILL AND SHE
HELD ME FOR DAY ENGLISH BY. I
JUST LACKEY WORK IS SO YOUR
NOVELS THEY BOTHERED IF THEY IF
AMELIA. GETTING FAMOUS DOUBLE C.
HALLS BANG THEN IF WITH LITTLE
BECAUSE THE PIANO.
I AM A PARTY LEADER AND I AM
HERE BECAUSE I WOULD LIKE BY THE
CHILDREN TO HAVE THE FUTURE
THAT.
YOU ARE TO BE OUR SUCCESSORS.
GET IT WAS GONNA THREATEN YOUR
THEY ALWAYS SAID IN A LIEU. PUT
LITTLE THEY WITH THIS AND ALSO
THOUGHT IF CUANDO YES THE THING
THAT ON THE CAN AM ASKING US
THOSE NINOS. SAMPLE MOST THEY
THIS CUANDO YO THING AGAIN.
WE WANT OUR CHILDREN TO BE LIKE
YOU WHEN THEY GROW UP.
EVEN I KNOW THAT IS SO THIS IS
THE THOMAS INVESTED IN A CASINO.
AND TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT WE
WILL WE HAVE TO INVEST IN THEIR
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOMEZ AMATORIA.
RACE.
ABOUT THIS BUT ANYWAY.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY MANY WITH
MARIA JAN THAT IS AND I'M ALSO A
PARTY LEADER FOR PRIME VOICE
THIS AND I'M HERE TO REPRESENT
WOMEN. AND MOTHERS AND
IMMIGRANTS THAT COME TO THIS
COUNTRY LOOKING FOR A BETTER FOR
A BETTER LIFE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN.
I CAME TO THIS COUNTRY WITH A
LAW DEGREE IN THE CANAL Y..
AND UNFORTUNATELY IT'S COSTLIEST
LENGTHY FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO
PRACTICE LAW HERE.
AND THEY STARTED WORKING UP IN A
LAW FIRM I WASN'T GETTING PAID
AS I SHOULD BE.
COMPENSATED.
BUT I CONTINUE I WANTED TO
CONTINUE MY HIGHER EDUCATION.
UNFORTUNATELY I WAS THE NOW
BARRY ABUSIVE AND INVOLVING A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
RELATIONSHIP I WAS PREGNANT.
AND IN ORDER FOR ME TO SUCCEED I
NEEDED TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL
FINISH MY HIGHER EDUCATION. AND
BE ABLE TO FIND A BETTER JOB FOR
ME AND FOR MY CHILDREN.
IT IT'S VERY HARD IS VERY
STRESSFUL MOTHERS GO THROUGH A
LOT OF TRAUMA.
AND WE NEED AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE
WERE HERE BECAUSE WE SUPPORT THE
ONE BILLION DOLLAR FOR.
THAT AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE AND
PASSED BY.
FRIEND MENTION IT IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT THAT WE INVEST IN THE
CHILDREN WITH OUR LITTLE.
SO NOW I'M A SURVIVOR FOR A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I ALREADY.
FINISHED MY PRO LEGAL
CERTIFICATE I EARN ANNA SOCIAL
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE.
.
S. ASSOCIATES DEGREE AND
CONTINUE WITH MY EDUCATION AND I
WANNA BE A VOICE FOR THOSE
PARENTS THAT. ARE NOT HERE TODAY
BUT THEY ARE IN THE SAME
SITUATION LET ME THAT NEEDED THE
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE STABLE
CHILD CARE FOR THE KIDS TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOL.
TO CONTINUE WITH THEIR EDUCATION
AND GET A BETTER FUTURE FOR THE
CHILDREN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS ELSE LIKE INDONESIA
AND I AM HERE ALSO TO TO PERCENT
PARENTS BOYS. IN MYSELF.
US OF A LOT OF PARENTS WE HAVE
OUR KIDS IN A WAY LEASES THERE'S
THERE'S MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTY KIDS. ON A WAITING
LIST.
TO FOR FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
ASSIST THROUGH A GOOD CHILDCARE
SO I AM HERE TO.
TO REPRESENT AND TO PLEASE ASK
YOU TO.
.
TO INVEST ON THAT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR EACH CHILD CARE.
MORNING WINNINGS VALLEY AREA
THIS I'M ALSO APPARENT FROM
PARENTS VOICES FRESNO CHAPTER.
AND I'M A FORMER CAL WORK RIGHT
THE RECIPIENT NOW THAT I HAVE TO
PAY FOR CHILDCARE BECAUSE I WAS
WRONGFULLY TERMINATED.
I CAN'T AFFORD CHILD CARE ON MY
OWN SO I HAVE TO ACTUALLY LEAVE
MY CHILD WITH MY FATHER WHO IS
CONSIDERED DISABLED.
I HAVE TO COME HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY THE IMPORTANCE OF
INCREASING THE EARLY CARE SLOTS
FOR PARENTS BECAUSE JUST AS
MYSELF IT'S VERY HARD FOR
PARENTS TO.
PAY FOR CHILD CARE WHEN THEY'RE
ON MINIMUM WAGE.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARY
MATIAS ON THE STATE WIDE
ORGANIZER FOR PAN VOICES THE
SERGEANTS GOING TO PASS OUT.
SOME PICTURES FROM A STUDY WE
DID A COUPLE YEARS AGO ACTUALLY
TALKING TO FAMILIES ON THE
WAITING LIST IN TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE SACRIFICES AND
ADDRESS THE CHILDCARE
DIFFICULTIES EMPLOYMENT
DIFFICULTIES CHILD DEVELOPMENT
AND PARENTAL STRESS AND THEY
PHOTOGRAPHED WHAT IT MEANT.
IN THEIR LIVES AND THROUGH
THEIR EYES.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY COME
PALLENE.
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING SEVENTY
TWO PERCENT OF THOSE THAT WERE
SURVEYED SAID THEY REFUSED A JOB
OFFER A QUIT SCHOOL. A EIGHTY
NINE PERCENT.
REPORTED EXPRESSING
EXPERIENCING STRESS BECAUSE THEY
DID HAVE CHILDCARE SEVENTY TWO
EXPRESSED AFFECTED THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH
ALSO WHILE THESE FAMILIES ARE
WAITING THERE ARE REAL. ON
NEGATIVE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING TO THEM AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND ALL THEY WANT IS
THE HAND UP.
TO HAVE THE ASSISTANCE TO HAVE
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE SO THEY CAN
WORK AND THEY CAN GO TO SCHOOL.
I LAST YEAR THINGS TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND THIS LEGISLATURE
WE WERE ABLE TO UPDATE THE
INCOME GUIDELINES AND IMPLEMENT
TWELVE MONTHS OF CHILDCARE
SUBSIDIES. THAT HAS STABILIZED
OUR SYSTEM AND NOW IT'S REALLY
TIME TO EXPAND THAT STABILITY TO
AS MANY FAMILIES AS WE CAN WHO
ARE ON THE WAITING LIST. SO WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT OF THE
EASY COALITIONS AT EXPANSION FOR
A BILLION DOLLARS A YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR ABOUT.
PROPOSAL TO FIX THE LICENSE
EXAM PROVIDER RATE FOR PART TIME
PROVIDERS OF THAT'S BEEN A JUST
A BUREAUCRATIC.
FIX THAT CAN BE EASILY
ADDRESSED.
AND WILL DEFINITELY ELIMINATE
THE GROSS INEQUITIES IN OUR
SYSTEM.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE OUR IN OUR
DATABASE THINK YOU THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CANDY
DEPEND WINE I WHAT PAM VOICES AM
I DID BRING A STORY THAT I WANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU HELLO PASSING.
STORIES ABOUT A MOM SHE'S
MARRIED AND SHE DOES HAVE TWO
CHILDREN AND SHE'S BEEN ON THIS
A WAITING LIST FOR. YEARS I
THINK UP TO FIVE YEARS AND SHE
WANTS TO TELL HER STORY SO SHE
COULD MAKE IT TODAY SO I WANT TO
BRING A CHAT WITH YOU THANK YOU.
HI LARA MADNESS DOLLAR FOR SEE
CINEMA OF FIRST THEY WANTED TO.
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THE C.
COALITIONS ASK
US SECONDLY.
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW I WAS
AND.
A FORUM YESTERDAY HOSTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND WAS ALL ABOUT CAREER
READINESS AND A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND EDUCATORS AND
EMPLOYERS.
CHILD CARE IN A PRESCHOOL CAME
UP AGAIN AND AGAIN AT THIS FORUM
AS BOTH A LACK OF CHILDCARE
BEING A BARRIER TO PARENTS BEING
ABLE TO FURTHER THEIR CAREER.
AND.
PRESCHOOL OUT AN EARLY
EDUCATION AS AN EQUITY ISSUE FOR
SCHOOL READINESS.
AND SECONDLY.
A WANTED TO URGE YOU TO.
CONSIDER REINSTATING THE STATE
MAIL MY AGENCY.
WE RUN THE FOOD PROGRAM IN
THREE DIFFERENT COUNTIES ADD A
SIGNIFICANT LOSS.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PROVIDERS AND CHILDREN IN
THOSE COUNTIES HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS PROGRAM MENU TRADITIONAL
MALES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING PATTY HER ARE
REPRESENTING EARLY EDGE
CALIFORNIA IT'S REALLY HARD TO
FOLLOW THE POWERFUL TESTIMONY OF
PARENTS.
BUT THAT SAID WE WANTED TO I'M
JUST ECHO OUR SUPPORT FOR THE E.
C. E. COALITIONS ONE BILLION
DOLLAR ASK
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO EARLY CHILD
CARE AND PRESCHOOL SYSTEM. WE
SIT WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
CONTINUED INVESTMENTS AND OUR
SYSTEM BUT WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
THE TIME TO EXPAND SO WE ARE WE
APPRECIATE THE.
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF OUR
REQUEST THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CREATION THEORY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL NETWORK WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT BILLION FOR
BABIES.
AND IN THAT WE OF COURSE
SUPPORT THAT ARE IN OUR
STATEWIDE DATABASE.
WHICH WOULD BRING US INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CCD BG WE
BEGIN TO BUILD AN INTEGRATED E.
C. E. TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM IN
CALIFORNIA BY LINKING THE WORK
FORCE DATABASE TO THE ART OUR
DATABASE. IT WOULD BUILD OUT
PARENTS AND PROVIDER PORTALS.
STRENGTHENING THE CONSUMER
EDUCATION.
ASPECT OF IT AND IMPLEMENT
WEBSITE IS UP DESIGNS THAT WERE
ACTUALLY TESTED ON PARENTS SO WE
KNOW THEY WOULD WORK.
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM THE
LAST FALL IT WOULD ABSOLUTELY BE
REALLY HELPFUL WITH FACILITATING
EMERGENCY RESPONDING RESPONSE
AND COMMUNICATION? AND PROVIDE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE.
DATA EFFICIENCY. AND WE WOULD
ALSO ADDED AN INTEGRATED SUBSIDY
TO MANDATE A BASED THAT.
WE ARE ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE
PRECEDED ME OF THAT FOOD PROGRAM
CA CFP.
SINCE THAT CALIFORNIA
ELIMINATED THE SUPPLEMENTAL
REIMBURSEMENTS WE SAW A
SIGNIFICANT DROP OFF A
PARTICIPATION IN THAT PROGRAM
AND IN MANY CASES THAT MEANS
THAT PROVIDERS CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS NO LONGER PROVIDE FOOD
IN THEIR PROGRAMS. BECAUSE THEY
THEMSELVES ARE FOOD INSECURE SO
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT FULL
BELLIES.
AND FINALLY WE SUPPORT THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION'S ASK
FOR HEALTHY AND CHILDCARE
SETTINGS MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
IN OURS PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT TO FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS TO. AND FROM
SAN FRANCISCO TO SAN DIEGO TO
PROVIDE HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS IN
THEIR THEIR CHILD CARE HOMES. ON
BUT THEY DO THIS WITHOUT ANY
SORT OF STATE FUNDING PROVIDER
BY PROVIDING GRANTS TO PROVIDERS
MANY OF WHOM ARE THEMSELVES AT
HIGH RISK FOR CHRONIC DISEASES
THAT COULD BE REDUCED THROUGH
BETTER EATING OR MORE MOVEMENTS.
WE SEE THAT THIS PROGRAM IS HAS
A TRIFLE BENEFIT NOT ONLY TO
CHILDREN BUT THE PROVIDERS OF
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THEN FINALLY ON THAT STAFF
COMMENT AROUND A. B. AP
ADMINISTRATIVE RATES MOST OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE ALSO AP CONTRACT
HOLDERS AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
SHARE. WITH YOU THAT THEY HAD
LOTS OF QUESTIONS
THANK YOU
AGAIN.
PAT A PRE NUMBER FROM THE CHILD
CARE LAW CENTER.
ALSO IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE E. C. E. ASK FOR.
A BILLION DOLLARS THERE IS AN
URGENT NEED FOR A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE VOUCHERS THAT
SERVE A PRIMARILY INFANTS AND
TODDLERS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT.
WE HAVE THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
ARE SLIGHTLY LESS OF THESE
VOUCHERS STATEWIDE RIGHT NOW
AND.
AS BOMB WAS PREVIOUSLY TESTIFIED
THERE ARE FORTY SIX THOUSAND
CHILDREN ON THE WAITING LIST IN
LA ALONE FOR THESE VOUCHERS.
I IT'S NOT NEAR ENOUGH TO MEET
THE STATEWIDE NEED AND IT IS
HOLDING US BACK WE REALLY SEE
THIS AS A SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITY FOR LAWMAKERS TO
HELP MORE FAMILIES PAY FOR
CHILDCARE. AND INVEST IN GROWING
THE SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE CARE
FOR BABIES AND TODDLERS.
AND BY DOING THAT AND SUPPORTING
CHILDREN FROM THE BEGINNING OF
THEIR LIFE IT WILL LAY THE
FOUNDATION FOR A BRIGHTER FUTURE
FOR EVERYONE THEY CHILDREN WILL
BE READY FOR SCHOOL. THANK YOU I
JUST WANT TO MENTION THAT WE OF
COURSE ARE ENDORSE AND SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO FIX THE LICENSE
EXEMPT HOURLY RATE.
TO MATCH LEGISLATIVE INTENT AND
PAY PEOPLE A SOMEWHAT MORE FAIR
WAGE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING NINA BUSY
CALIFORNIA CHILD DEVELOPMENT
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION AND
I'M JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THIS HEARING
TODAY.
HOW WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MULTI YEAR BUDGET
PROPOSAL BUT AS YOU ALREADY
NOTED CHAIRMAN THIS WAS AN
AGREEMENT THAT WE ALREADY AGREED
ON LAST YEAR SO WE ARE LOOKING
AT SOME EXPANSION AND I'M IN
THIS YEAR? A WE DO WANT TO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE EASY E.
COALITION I REQUEST.
IN PARTICULAR I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW TO TAX ON.
INCREASING THE INFANT TODDLER
FACTORS FOR TITLE FIVE PROGRAMS
ON WILL BE INTERCOLLEGIATE TERMS
OF AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
CONSERVE MORE FOR INFANT
TODDLERS IN HIGH QUALITY ON
CHILDCARE SETTINGS.
ADDITIONALLY REESTABLISHING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT DAYS
FOR TITLE FIVE PROGRAMS THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS ELIMINATED AS
PART OF THE GREAT RECESSION I
MEAN TWENTY TEN SO WE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE THOSE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING DAYS BACK.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
REINSTATE THE ON CALIFORNIA
SUPPLEMENT FOR THE CHILD AND
ADULT FOOD PROGRAM AGAIN THIS
WAS ELIMINATED AS PART OF THE
GREAT RECESSION IN TWENTY
TWELVE.
I'M SO WE REALLY SEE THESE ADS
ON HELPING TO MAKE OUR SYSTEM
ROBUST ON AND CONTINUE TO INVEST
OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN.
ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
START UP PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
CROSS FOR PROGRAMS SO THAT
ANYONE WHO DOES WANT TO
TRANSITION A PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
TO AN INFANT TODDLER CLASSROOM
HAS THE ABILITY TO DO SO. I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU HEARING.
SOME OF OUR REQUESTS TODAY AND
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATION ON THESE ITEMS
THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL FRANK AND I AM JOINED
HER BY FOR MY COLLEAGUES I'M THE
PROUD PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS INSTITUTE. THIS
AFTERNOON OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM WILL SERVE OVER THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED UNITS WITHIN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
I WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO THANK YOU FOR THE BUDGET
INCREASE THAT DIRECTLY IMPACT
THE STUDENTS WE SERVE. WITH THE
SIXTY NINE CENTS INCREASE WE
SERVE MORE STUDENTS SOME BEFORE
AND PROVIDE A QUALITY PROGRAM IN
WHICH THE STUDENTS ARE
DESPERATELY IN NEED OF.
WITH MINIMUM WAGE INCREASING
EVERY YEAR WE ARE CONFIDENT.
THAT IF THE PROPOSED BUDGET IS
PASSED WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
A SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR YOUTH
THAT WOULD TEACH THEM THE LIFE
SOCIAL AND ACADEMIC SKILLS. THEY
NEED TO GROW UP TO BE SUCCESSFUL
ADULTS.
MY PARENTS ARE COUNTING ON YOUR
VOTE TO SUPPORT AFTER SCHOOL SO
THEY CAN CONTINUE GOING TO WORK
AND PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES
OUR STUDENTS ARE COUNTING ON
YOUR SUPPORT. SET THE SAFE PLACE
THEY GO TO AFTER SCHOOL.
DOES NOT DISAPPEAR AS THE AFTER
SCHOOL PROFESSIONAL I THINK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JESSICA
GUNNARSSON I'M REPRESENTING THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AND THE CALIFORNIA AFTER
SCHOOL ADVOCACY ALLIANCE WHICH
REPRESENTS.
OVER TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE THAT SERVE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF KIDS
EACH DAY WE SUPPORT.
.
WE APPRECIATE THAT ASSEMBLY
SUPPORT LAST YEAR FOR AN
INCREASED RATE. UP BUT WITH THE
STATUTORY MINIMUM WAGE GOING UP
EACH YEAR THOSE COST PRESSURES
OF NOT CHANGED SO WE PROVIDED.
PACKETS FOR ALL THE MEMBERS
SPECIFICALLY OUTLINING THE
DEFICITS THAT ARE PROGRAMS ARE
FACED WITH. A WE CONDUCTED A
SURVEY IN DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN SO JUST
THE LAST FEW MONTHS. AND WE'VE
HEARD FROM OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT SAID THEY
WOULD CLOSE THE DOOR. I'M IN THE
NEXT TWO YEARS WE DO NOT SEE
INCREASES IN THAT I'M A SAYS
DAILY RATES AS WELL AS STE OVER
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT BY PROGRAMS
ARE HAVING MAJOR CHALLENGES
RECRUITING. AND RETAINING A
DIRECT LINE STAFF WHICH I THE
NUMBER ONE INDICATOR FOR PART OF
OUR PROGRAMS. ON AND THE SAFETY
OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. AND
THEN ADDITIONALLY ON BEHALF OF
THE PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH WE WANNA.
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR THE
BREAKFAST AFTER THE BELL PROGRAM
WE BEEN DOING OUTREACH TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FOR THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. AND RECKLESSLY ON
PEOPLE'S FUNDAMENTAL TO SCHOOL
IN MY SUCCESS SO I THINK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS LISA HENSON I'M
WITH GROWING BILLION PRESCHOOL
ACADEMY WE FOUND MY HUSBAND I
OWN AND OPERATE FOR PRESCHOOLS
IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA.
WHAT WE OFFER LICENSE PROGRAMS
TO INFANTS THROUGH SCHOOL AGE
I'M WE HAVE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS WHILE? I'M WE WORK WITH
CHILD ACTION IN PCO WE'D OFFER
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING ON TO MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS.
WE'D LOVE TO SEE SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING EXPANDED FOR CHILDREN
ATTENDING PRIVATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS ON PARENTS OF CHILDREN
OF THIS AGE NEED AS MANY CHOICES
AS POSSIBLE FOR THEIR LITTLE
ONES.
SO WE'D LIKE TO ADVOCATE FOR
THAT THE PRIVATE SECTOR AS WELL
AND I'M FIGHTING THE CHOICES TO
FAMILIES.
THANK YOU.
ALAMEDA NARROWED CALIFORNIANS
FOR QUALITY EARLY LEARNING AND I
ECHO ALL THE TESTIMONIES BEFORE
ME SO I WON'T BELABOR ANYTHING.
OTHER THAN TO SAY THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY STRONG
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
IT'S A MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM WE
NEED TO PRESERVE OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IMPRENTA CHOICE AND
ACCESS.
BY EXPANDING ONLY DOLLARS SO ANY
NEW DOLLARS ARE SLOTS THAT COME
INTO IMPROVE QUALITY ARE ACCESS.
GOES OUT TO ALL PROVIDER TYPES
INCLUSIVE TO ENHANCE.
ACCESSIBILITY AND QUALITY TO
CHILD CARE THANK YOU.
A MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
MCKAY WE ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AS YOU KNOW MISTER
CHAIR A COMP TN TECHNOLOGIES ARE
CO SPONSORS OF YOUR AB TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT. HOPEFULLY
AMENDMENTS WILL BE IN THAT.
BILL AND PRINT.
LATER THIS WEEK TO ESTABLISH A
THREE YEAR CODING FOR KIDS GRANT
PROGRAM. AYE AS YOU'RE FAMILIAR
CALIFORNIA FACES A A REAL
SHORTAGE AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY.
DEGREES PARTICULARLY CODING
SKILLS AND AT THE SAME TIME OUR
BENCH IS VERY THIN IN THIS
REGARD STUDIES SHOW THAT ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE HIGH
SCHOOLS OFFER ANY CODING
EDUCATION. THE NUMBER IS EVEN
SMALLER WITH THOSE FOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS SO WE URGE
YOU THREW AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT
IN THIS BUDGET REQUEST.
FOR THOSE DOLLARS FOR AFTER KID
AFTER SCHOOL I KIDS CODING
PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR JUST
AS ON BEHALF OF TECHNO ALLY MY
COMMENTS WAS THAT MR MCHALE IS
IN. THE AIR AFTER SCHOOL KIDS
GRANT PROGRAM THANK YOU.
SYLVIA SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THAT CALIFORNIA AT AFTER
SCHOOL ADVOCACY ALLIANCE
PROPOSAL FOR INCREASED FUNDING
FOR THE AFTER SCHOOL SAFETY. AND
EDUCATION PROGRAM A HUNDRED AND
TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS AND LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM IS
PARTICIPANTS ARE TWENTY PERCENT
LESS LIKELY THAN NON
PARTICIPANTS DROP OUT OF SCHOOL
AND THIRTY PERCENT LESS LIKELY
THAN NON PARTICIPANTS TO COMMIT
THE JUVENILE CRIME TO SPENDING
WILL. AND INCREASED SLOTS
AVAILABLE FOR MORE STUDENTS SO
WE ASK YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARTHA SARAH GOES A
D. AS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND WE
SUPPORT THE ONE BILLION DOLLAR
BUT TO ASK OF THE ECB COALITION.
FOR ALL OF THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS
MY TENT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CRISTINA MARCELLUS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUBS.
ALIGNING OURSELVES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL NETWORK
IN THE PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN
YOUTH IN SUPPORT OF THE SEVENTY
SIX POINT THREE MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE THIS YEAR. FOR THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK
YOU.
MORNING KRIS LIVE TWENTY WITH A
CALIFORNIA STATE ALLIANCE OF
YMCAS HERE IN SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL ADVOCACY
ALLIANCE REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE ACES PROGRAM.
ARE YMCAS SERVE ABOUT THIRTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS AT THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE SITES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE REASONS PUT
FORTH BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION REQUEST THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT THIS.
MORNING BARRETT CENTER AT THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S.
EARLY ACCESS PROPOSAL ALSO.
A POINT ON THE.
CHILDCARE FACILITIES REVOLVING
LOAN FUND. OTHER WAS YOUR
APPLICATIONS LAST YEAR BECAUSE A
LOT OF PROVIDERS CAN'T MEET
REPAYMENT OBLIGATIONS LIKE IT
UNDER THE TEN YEAR PLAN. THERE'S
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS HERE
WE WOULD SUGGEST POTENTIALLY
CONCERN RE PURPOSING OF DOLLARS
YOU COULD USE THEM FOR EXAMPLE
TO.
HAVE EARLY CARE PROVIDERS
RETROFIT FACILITIES FOR STUDENTS
SPECIAL NEEDS IS A GOOD WAY TO
USE THAT MONEY SO WITH UP TO.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ERIC
ONLY THEN I'M WITH STUDENT
SUCCESS INSTITUTE. AND I JUST
WANNA SEE THE IMPORTANCE ABOUT
THEIR SCHOOL AS A PRODUCT OF
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS THEY'VE
SEEN THE IMPACT AND THE BENEFITS
THAT IT IS FOR THESE CHURCHES
THAT WE SERVE IN THE COMMUNITY
AND I JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
HI CHAIRMAN.
MCCARTY AND BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
MINIMUM MEMBERS MY NAME IS LAW
THE LONG FROM FACES SF WE MANAGE
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED CHILDREN THAT
I'M ENTITLED FIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
WE'RE REQUESTING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR
SUPPORT TITLE FIVE RATE
INCREASES FOR PROVIDERS WHO
CONTINUALLY OFFER EXCEPTIONAL
HIGH QUALITY. EARLY LEARNING.
EDUCATION TO WORKING FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE FUNDS PRIMARILY WILL GO TO
ATTRACT STRENGTHENED AND BILL.
AND RETAIN DIVERSE HIGH QUALITY
WORKFORCE.
WHO EVERYDAY TEACHER YOUNGEST
CHILDREN?
THIS INVESTMENT WILL HAVE
DIVIDENDS FOR WORKING FAMILIES
FOR A LIFETIME AND THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS UPLAND
TAURUS WITH MISSION NEIGHBORHOOD
CENTER I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR EQUITY.
IN EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION AYE
AYE SIR COALITION WE HAVE DONE
FOR THREE PRIORITIES ON ONE
WOULD BE RATES IMPRISONED
TODDLERS AND THIRD.
CAPITAL OUTLINE I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE ALREADY HIGHLIGHTED
NOT A THINGS SO I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THE ASK.
I'M FOR THE RATES.
NETS VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE WE ARE REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO SUPPORT RATE
INCREASE.
SO THAT WE MAY BUILD AND
STRENGTHEN AND DIVERSE AND HIGH
QUALITY TEACHING WORKFORCE THAT
OUR CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES
NEED.
AND REGARDS THE INFANT TODDLERS.
AS YOU KNOW THE FIRST THREE
YEARS OF A CHILD'S A BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT IS VERY IMPORTANT.
SO WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL
REINVEST IN NEW EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION SPACES ADEQUATE PER
CHILDREN FUNDING AGE APPROPRIATE
FACILITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AND. START OF SUPPORT AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR OUR
FOR ALL CARE SETTINGS AND LASTLY
OF THE CAPITAL OUTLAY ON THE
LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT
HAS CREATED OPPORTUNITY BARRIERS
FOR MANY MANY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. SO WE ARE ASKING THAT
THE STATE PROVIDE A ONE TIME
START UP FUNDING PERSONALITY
PROJECT AS WELL AS CONSIDER A
VERSION. OF EXISTING REVOLVING
LOAN FUND TO GRANT FOR EASY EASY
E. PROVIDERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
GOOD MORNING I'M KEVIN HICKEY
FROM JEWISH VOCATIONAL SERVICE
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE PARTNERING
WITH ECT PROVIDERS TO TRAIN AND
PLACE ARM YOUNG ADULTS IN THE
ECB WORKFORCE SYSTEM.
WE ECHO THE CALL FOR AN
INCREASE IN REIMBURSEMENT RATES
AS A MEANS TO INCREASE. OUR
WAGES AREN'T WE NEED TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION FROM POVERTY WAGES
TO WAGES THAT SUPPORT FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO HEAR
TIME AND AGAIN FROM EMPLOYERS
THAT THE LACK OF HIGH QUALITY
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE IS A
BARRIER TO BUSINESS SUCCESS.
AND LASTLY WITH THE TRINITY
COLLEGE AND CSU SYSTEMS
INVESTING TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN THE TRAINING OF THE
C. E. TEACHERS IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE TO LEVERAGE THOSE
INVESTMENTS BY INVESTING IN OUR
HIGH QUALITY HEALTHY WORKFORCE
UPON GRADUATION. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MONICA WALTERS A
CEO WE CHILDREN SERVICES IN SAN
FRANCISCO WERE EARLY HEAD START
HAD STARTED TITLE FIVE PROVIDERS
SERVING OVER SIX HUNDRED.
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME CHILDREN
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO AREA AND
WE'RE WITH THE EASY.
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION OUT
COALITION.
I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE
KNOW WE NEED THE MIXED DELIVERY
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE A VARIETY OF
NEEDS FOR OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS.
FROM OUR CHILD CARE IN FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOMES.
BUT I DON'T WANNA.
REALLY I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
NEED FOR TITLE FIVE QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING AS WELL AS A PART
OF THAT SYSTEM. AND RIGHT NOW
THE.
THE RATES ARE STILL ARM UNDER
AYE INADEQUATE FOR US TO
PROVIDE.
THE KIND OF.
.
PROFESSIONAL COMPENSATION THAT
OUR TEACHERS DESERVE. SO WE
REALLY ARE ASKING FOR AN
INCREASE IN RATES.
ALONG WITH THE INFANT TODDLER
ADJUSTMENT FACTOR. AND MORE A
DOLLARS FOR AYE FACILITIES.
THOSE ARE THE THREE MAIN THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO TO REALLY
CONTINUE. TO PREPARE.
OUR EARLY LEARNERS FOR QUALITY.
.
AN ABILITY TO SUCCEED IN
KINDERGARTEN THANK YOU.
DIONNE AARON ARE ON BEHALF OF
STATE COUNCIL OF SEIU AND ALSO
UNITED.
DULL.
THAT'S ME OF UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS WE'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM
ACTUALLY I'M WHAT PART OF THE
EASY COALITION SO I WON'T GO
OVER THAT SUPPORT RIGHT YOU'VE
HEARD ENOUGH ABOUT THAT WE ALSO
WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT WERE.
IN SUPPORT OF THE FOOD POLICY
ADVOCATES TO REQUEST REGARDS TO
OF INCREASING THE DAILY RATE FOR
IT FOR MEALS FOR ARE PURELY FOR
A FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
WHO YOU HEARD. MANY OF THEM HAVE
LEFT THE PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD IT AND ALSO WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE DATABASE
RESTORING OUR NETWORKS REQUEST
WE NEED THAT VERY BADLY TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A STATEWIDE
DATABASE BECAUSE THAT WAY WE CAN
GIVE YOU BETTER INFORMATION. ON
A REGULAR BASIS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M HEATHER CLEARY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF PENINSULA
FAMILY SERVICE WE OPERATE NINE
EARLY LEARNING CENTERS IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY SERVING FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY CHILDREN. AT AN
INCREASE IN TITLE FIVE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES IS AN
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES. LOW REIMBURSEMENT
RATES RESULT IN CLOSING
CLASSROOMS DUE TO A FUNDING IN
TEACHER SHORTAGE SO CHILDREN GO
TO KINDERGARTEN UNPREPARED ALL
WHILE PARENTS ARE UNABLE TO
WORK.
NEW TEACHERS AREN'T ENTERING THE
FIELD BECAUSE OF THE PAY AND
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH CURRENT
TEACHERS TO MEET DEMAND.
THIS LACK OF ACCESS RESULT IN
CHILDREN WHO BOTH PHYSICALLY AND
MENTALLY ARE NOT READY FOR
KINDERGARTEN. THIS IS VERY
COSTLY TO THE PUBLIC.
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION AND
INTERVENTION PROVISION ORAL
HEALTH HEARING MOBILITY SPEECH
AND DRAMA. ARE CRITICAL FOR A
CHILD SUCCESS.
AND OF COURSE THE MOST.
EXPENSIVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
PARENTS WHO WANT TO WORK ARE
UNABLE TO WORK BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE A SAFE TRUSTED PLACE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT WRAPS IT UP OUT
GOING TO TELL EVERYBODY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION WE I
HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR THAT
THESE ISSUES HAVE BEEN A.
PRIORITY FOR THE ASSEMBLY IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IN THERE WILL BE
AGAIN HOW WE KNOW WE NEED TO
INVEST IN OUR HUMAN CAPITAL.
FOR OUR KIDS AND OUR FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND WE
NEED TO SAVE FOR A RAINY DAY BUT
AS WE HEARD EARLIER FOR SOME
MONEY IT'S RAINING AND POURING.
ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA FOR FOR
LITERALLY.
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES AND
YOUNGSTERS AND SO WILL KEEP THIS
IN MIND WHEN WE TAKE OUR FINAL
ACTION IN A FEW MONTHS THANK YOU